Elon Musk has now visited the Border
exactly as many times as KLA Harrison
Joe Biden which is one I think that's
true I don't know I saw it on Twitter so
fact check that one but Elon Musk is
currently down at the border and he just
did two live streams from Eagle Pass in
Texas showing illegal immigration and he
he says he backs a border wall so Elon
Musk is coming out saying build the wall
going under the Border I think it's
really interesting as to he chose to do
it first and foremost it's a big story I
do think he is testing the capabilities
of live streaming on X formerly Twitter
and so this is a big deal for him to go
out and and provide coverage of this
will generate a ton of attention very
very good for the platform so we'll
definitely talk about all that oh boy
Jen yuger may be announcing a run for
the presidency and this is the host of
The Young Turks I say may because the
official headlines are that he's
announced Staffing for he's Staffing up
for a 2024 run something to the effect
of no one else will do it and we have no
choice Biden can't win so apparently
he's going to run but we'll see I don't
think he actually declared he's running
and no one ever does because then
there's much of legal ramifications and
then the winner of last night's GOP
debate was Donald Trump for real a poll
was put out they found Donald Trump won
even though he was not there V came in
second place and then Joe Biden has
started using quotes from Ronda santis
to attack Donald Trump so Bravo GOP
lesser known candidates who are not
going to be president all you're doing
is helping Joe Biden congratulations
we're going to talk about all that
before we do head over to
timcast.net
now we're going to be in Miami October 6
Friday 6:00 to 10:30 p.m. live it is
going to be a heck of a fun show so I
strongly advise all of you to pick up
your tickets and head down to Miami it's
going to be it's going to be a blast
we've got Patrick B David James o'keef
Matt Gates Lukowski I will be there Ian
will be there a bunch of special guests
the timcast crew many people will be
there we're going to have Alex Stein
doing a pre-show set on stage for all of
you a bunch of free swag sponsored by
Public Square where huge fans download
the Public Square app super awesome and
for those of you that would like to
watch at home click join us become a
member because October 6's Friday Night
episode is going to be uncensored and
only available to members on
timcast.net more substantial for our
members but it also allows us to kind of
go completely off the rails we're going
to have people in the audience who knows
what they'll be yelling at yelling up at
stage and I was like you know someone
asked how do we control for that if
someone yells something that's bad and
it's like we can't and it's like let's
do it members only right consider it a
we're really hoping we we get you guys
to sign up to support our work we're
putting a ton of effort this has been
like a year in the works it's very very
hard to pull off plus getting all these
amazing guests to come we really do need
your support so if you like the work we
do and you like all the crazy cultural
stuff we're doing click join us and
we're going to have a members only show
coming up for you tonight at 10 p.m. and
you get to join the membersonly Discord
and talk with like-minded people 247
they got pre-shows they got after shows
they got Hangouts they're building
culture they're working on games they're
working on music and you can be a part
of this and I hope you do because we're
trying to build culture so smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends joining
us tonight to talk about this and a
whole lot more is Dan Lyman Good To Be
With You Tim thanks so much for having
me right on who are you what do you do
um I run border Hawk which is an
immigration only newssite border hawk.
newws and I'm also a correspondent for
Infowars right on well thanks for
hanging out you should be a blast
especially with the Elon stuff I think
we'll have a lot to talk about
definitely we got Phil leonti hello
everybody my name is Phil leonti lead
singer of All That Remains very failed
musician anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary Libby hi everybody
I'm Libby Emmons I am I am here I'm here
I'm here again twice in one week it's
very exciting for me so what do you do I
am the editor-in-chief of the post
Millennial and human events.com right on
yeah and uh I'm here it's weird to hear
you say failed musician like that it's a
just funny to me it's so much fun yeah
it's a good one anyways yeah I'm
surge.com ready when you are to when's
the sixth gold record coming is it going
to be like probably next year is when
I'll actually get it Tak time for the
once once's it
officially I'm I'm I'm not exactly sure
but I think it'll be it'll be done
probably in another six weeks or so when
I actually get the certification
the sixth I'm not I'm not I I don't I
don't want to predict a date I'm waiting
on the ra you did get the fifth is now
like there you go failed musician there
it is everybody all right let's let's uh
let's jump into the news we got this
tweet from Elon Musk I didn't call it a
tweet call it a Twix Twix a post Twix
look at this I love that this is the uh
look how silly this looks this is
ridiculous Elon Musk went to Eagle Pass
and started live streaming at the border
during the immigration crisis I'm glad
he's doing it I'm glad he's making this
a major issue Elon going there
makes this bigger news for everyone it's
fantastic but this picture is just so
silly look at he's got like the guy
behind him all Smiley and you know
whatever it's funny but he did two live
streams and this one you can actually
see there illegal immigrants that are
behind this I don't know orange chicken
wire or some sort and then we have this
from The Daily Mail Elon Musk reveals he
backs the border wall and says migrants
must have a shred of evidence to claim
for Asylum days after announcing visit
to crisis hit Eagle Pass so look man
right now at Eagle Pass they're just
people are just flowing in there's
there's CBP allowing them in and then
they're all being shipped up to various
cities where we end up with mass
protests the scariest thing I I want to
make sure everybody understands because
I'm seeing these leftists on Twitter be
like who cares okay well the people in
Staten Island are the ones who are
getting all of these people dumped in
their neighborhoods and now the police
are beating and arresting the locals so
yeah it it matters and uh Elon Musk
parachuting in is good because it
highlights the problem yeah and elon's
done a really good job um lately of
paying attention to this issue months
ago we were covering the fact that he
was you know doing his exclamation point
tweet you know response to people which
you know uh it's not him saying anything
he's just calling attention to it with
this massive massive uh magnifying glass
that he has and he's been indicating
that more and more this is concerning
him and so the fact that he's going down
there right now is so important because
of course we see so many of our elected
officials in in high powerered you know
uh right up all the way through the
presidency they they just can't even be
bothered bothered with the whole thing
and uh in the past month uh Eagle Pass
is averaging around 2,000 illegal
Crossings per day that's a lot and
that's one location right one location
it has been The Hot Spot pretty much for
the entire Biden border crisis um but uh
recently it's gotten even worse it was
bad every day all day but recently we
hit a a day record a single day record
which was about 2,200 and two days later
it was 4,000 and so it's it's getting
worse worse and worse I've heard that
because of the because of you know South
America has the summer in our winter
that the springtime come March and April
is going to be when it it tends to bump
up the most and if we're getting you
know 2,000 people a day or 3,000 people
a day at at one of the high volume
border crossings come March it's going
to be insane without some kind of change
in policy just in time for the election
I mean I don't want I you think Biden
would be doing everything in his power
right now put a to this because it's
just in time for the election I don't
know that's why I'm like do they want to
lose running Joe Biden and a border
crisis cuz immigration is a huge issue
when you have people in New York City
protesting AOC over immigration yeah
y'all Democrats are in trouble yeah
they're screaming at the buses they're
like yelling at everybody telling them
to go home New York City actually today
I saw a flyer that they put out that's
from the from the city of New York
saying go somewhere else you're not
going to be housed here this is a very
expensive city you will be better off
somewhere else the city is doing that
Democrats and this comes of course only
a couple weeks after Eric Adams said
they're destroying the city which they
are I me it's turning into a nightmare
absolutely and you're watching these
liberals that have been you know crowing
about the city being a sanctuary City
and across the country they've been
doing this well they're getting a taste
of their own medicine I'll be perfectly
honest I wasn't a fan of the busing
stunt that Texas launched last year I
thought it was basically just them
participating in the redistribution
right illegals and and we know for a
fact that the the amount that are in New
York City for instance it's only about
10% were bust there by Texas the other
90% are coming in uh of their own accord
being brought in by NOS being brought in
by the bid Administration maybe even
flying in we're learning now straight to
JFK so um it's only about 10% but it's
been quite effective and it has really
highlighted the hypocrisy the the the
defense of the of the you know busing
the people from the border to Texas was
well he can't Deport them anyway and I'm
just like my attitude is is kind of look
man if you have to choose between
sending a bus to New York and just
returning them to Mexico in violation of
I don't know federal law or whatever i'
I'd go with like hey man they entered
illegally we won't we won't we're not
we're going to send them right back and
then let let Mexico send uh
communication over how we deal with this
but if these people have already
illegally entered Mexico or they are
Mexican citizens then I don't see what
the argument is for some kind of like I
I I don't even think it's I think it's
some kind of treaty or something or like
international relations must be held by
the federal government and so what
happens is they come in and Texas is
like well we can't do anything the
federal government won't let us so they
put him on a bus and they send him to
New York I I like some of it right it it
it created a shock to the system it
created press but I think you're right
if if they didn't do this at all imagine
if Texas Florida and you know whatever
Arizona whichever other states were
doing it never did they'd still have a
migrant crisis in New York City they'd
still be saying the same things only now
they have a scapegoat now they can say
it's Republicans that are doing it on
purpose right that's interesting and
then you also had DeSantis sending
people to Martha's Vineyard which was
sort of an amazing stunt I thought yeah
that was that was brilliant that was
good sending a small handful of people
to a sanctuary city that has the means
to support them I think was better for
the people the the migrants themselves
got one of the best deals ever you're
going to Martha's Vineyard baby I never
even pretty nice and then it made the
people at the view and all these other
liberals lose their minds in panic the
more you can make people that have the
luxury opinion of open borders the more
you can make them feel the repercussions
from that the better right like because
it's real easy when you live in you know
the Northeast I'm from New Hampshire you
know Massachusetts it's easy to say oh
you should let people in they everyone
should be able to come in ETC um because
you don't feel the daily pressures that
you know that number of people
constantly straining your infrastructure
they don't feel it so if you can get
them
to partake in the actual you know the
actual reality of suffering of it yeah I
mean fair enough I was trying to be a
little a little more uh a little more
specific with my words but uh but yeah
essentially if you can make them feel
the pain then that's a good thing
because until most people have that
luxury have luxury opinions that don't
they don't they don't affect them so
they're like well it's okay for this
because someone else will deal with it
it's very very easy to say it's someone
else's problem it's really hard to say
it's someone else's problem when you
can't walk out your door without
stepping in human feces you know right
New York already had that problem San
Francisco I mean my attitude is kind of
uh at this point everybody should be uh
as self-sufficient as possible they
should be doing what they can to get out
of cities to get more I mean look it's
just you're better off we've got the we
got we have we have a video that we'll
talk about for in the members only
section tonight where it's uh students
fighting at high school is a trans
student fighting uh beating up uh but we
we we'll we'll save that but my point is
not to Hash that story out before we get
to it these things are happening in your
schools in these in these districts
where they've got these this weird
wokeness ideology you need to get away
from these places you need to be you
need to be self-sufficient
self-sustainable because it's clear the
government does not have your back
Staten Island is the perfect example of
social order breakdown Philadelphia is
the next best example they bring in
illegal immigrants into Staten Island
when the locals say hey man you can't do
this is our neighborhood the cops beat
and arrest them and then you get
Philadelphia where people run around 100
people running around smash teenagers
smashing up storefronts and stealing
iPhones iPads fighting with cops getting
and and only half of them get arrested
social order breakdown is happening does
it completely break down till it doesn't
exist I don't know but ain't nobody
coming to save you even if Trump gets
arrested you got to still deal with the
on the ground stuff happening your what
what did I say you said arrested oh no
no elected got right he already got a
res if Donald Trump gets elected he's
it's it's it's it's going to help I I
hope I believe there is a strong
probability that gets things back on
track but it still means the swamp is
all around you you may hope that Trump
pulls that plug and drains a lot of it
but it's going to be there for a while
you don't clean up this mess overnight
so that being said The more I see this
stuff the more I'm hoping that people
become self-sufficient and remove
yourself from ramifications of the
horrible policy so if you're not in New
York City you're going like wow that's
that's too bad for the people who live
there who voting who are voting for this
it does suck for the people who are
there who don't want it but at a certain
point I'm kind of thinking like the only
way this is resolved is is is getting
resolved or will be resolved is because
people in New York City are now
experiencing the problem when it was
just a Texas problem they said who cares
you're crazy now that it's a New York
problem now you're going to get the
whole country screaming about illegal
immigration finally and you had recently
a video of Chicago residents who most of
them were presumably Democrats berating
the city council and saying and in you
know essentially paraphrasing what they
said but almost a direct quote if you
don't do something about this we're
going to do something about this and
you're not going to like what that's
crazy that's scary man we don't none of
that yeah and there's a there's a lot of
black Democrats in Chicago who are
really fed up with this too I thought
that was really interesting too for a
minute I kind of had this hope that
perhaps there would be an abolition of
color lines and we could all just be
like we're Americans you guys are
Invaders I'm sorry that your country is
going to going hell over there but uh we
don't want ours to have that happen to
it I said this yesterday I really need
to say it again because I I because not
look for people who watch every show you
hear me say some things a couple times
maybe a lot but not everybody watches
every show imagine what it must be like
and I I can only imagine I'm not black
right but imagine you're a Democrat
black or white The Narrative is black
people have been oppressed by this
country and are owed for it reparations
should be paid now imagine you are a
black voter and many of you watching
probably are and you're being told over
and over again how much you're owed from
the because of what this country has
done to you then they say but don't
worry we're not going to give you money
every four years we'll dangle the carrot
in front of your face we're going to
claim we owe you the money then we're
going to open the Border bring in people
who don't even live here who've not
experienced anything we've claimed
you've experienced and then we're going
to give them money it's it's it's it's
at that point you know my attitude is
kind of like if you don't give me money
I'm not going to cry about it just don't
take my tax dollars but if you dangle
the money in front of me
saying like yeah this is your money you
know we don't worry we're going to get
it to you oh who's that guy here you go
buddy you you toss him a chunk of cash
now I'm pissed off well that was the
thing too in New York is they were
bringing in illegal immigrants setting
up a whole tent city type of things
giving them free Xboxes and stuff moving
homeless New Yorkers out of shelters I
mean there was already there were
already plenty of homeless in New York
New Yorkers families people with jobs
who can't afford to live there but they
have a job their families are they're
like trying to make it work and these
people these New Yorkers were moved out
of the shelters that were built for New
Yorkers um so that illegal immigrants
could come in all because of stupid Joe
Biden and the thing too about that is
the you know the situation in New York
where there was a sanctuary City and
also where there's a right to shelter
law which means that if someone shows up
and asks for a place to sleep the law is
you have to give it to them that only
works if you're dealing with the you
know the homeless residents of your own
City it doesn't work when you're dealing
with 100,000 people from wherever who
also are not assimilated they don't want
to assimilate and we have Progressive
saying you shouldn't assimilate you know
so there was a case today someone was an
illegal immigrant was arrested for
allegedly um raping a seven-year-old
girl in an airport hotel God you have
the Roosevelt Hotel we had a reporter go
out for human events Jackie toov and she
was saying that the hotel is essentially
culturally divided it's like um
Hispanics on one side and Africans on on
another and there's fights on the corner
you know I mean what a mess when you had
immigrants coming through Ellis Island
the idea was they were going to
assimilate their kids were American and
you and they could be they could be
adequately placed yes so we know hey
your new family's coming in we got we
have we have locations in this area
where we can help you get set up and
that way people integrate into the
society when people come here illegally
they just go and they find out where
their friends are and they create hon
claves I don't blame them for doing it's
what humans do but then you end up
with isolated Min societies right like
neighborhoods that don't view themselves
as part of the greater uh uh City or or
state or whatever and then no go zones
if that allowed to proliferate
proliferate even further but you know I
had a lot of relatives that came in my
family tree and um that came through New
York City they immigrated there and when
they were coming through you had to
provide chest x-rays right you had to
provide a sponsor that was was already
in the you had to have like five bucks
you or something you had to maybe like I
think you had to have some amount of
cash but you also couldn't have a job
already lined up right because the deal
was you couldn't be taking a job from an
American already here and now you have
AOC and hakee D Jeff and all of these
people coming out being like we have to
make sure they can get jobs people in
New York need jobs New Yorkers need jobs
Jack Jack Fresco made a great point that
I brought up earlier today he uh he was
in an interview the Z guy Z Z Zeitgeist
stuff if you guys are familiar with that
documentary he said when he was a kid
during the Depression he saw people in
an unemployment line and across the
street was a factory with no workers and
he was like why can't we get the workers
and the unemployment line into the
factory well he wasn't literally saying
you could he was saying like this is an
issue of a failed economic State the
workers from the unemployment line
couldn't necessarily do the job at the
factory so you have people who need work
and place that needs workers and it
can't make it work but from
understanding that principle if you've
got let's just flat numbers 100 jobs in
your town and you've got 110 people okay
you've got 10 people who need jobs some
people die some people move out now
there's a few job openings 50 illegal
immigrants come in no let's say 10 let's
say just 10 right
10% they start taking up these jobs and
the left argues that the immigrants
create demand and create jobs yes but
not immediately so what happens is these
jobs are going to be filled based on
Market competition some of these
businesses are going to say well we're
going to hire these guys more
importantly AOC is saying they're going
to get work permits for these
non-citizens which means if you're
someone struggling to find work AOC is
going to make sure one of these guys
takes the jobs that are available that
you should be getting exactly and then
maybe maybe in a year or two the demand
will increase enough to where more jobs
will will will come into fruition but
ain't nobody's creating a job at their
business based off of a week a month or
a couple months exactly if Revenue
increases over like let's say like 100
illegal immigrants come into my
neighborhood and now I'm selling more
cheeseburgers yes at the end of the
month I'll calculate how much money I
made how much how many more Burgers I
got to buy what my profits were and then
we'll carry on maybe after six months
I'll say okay you know demand is getting
is getting greater and greater we're
going to bring out some more employees
but it's not going to be right away
right no it's not going to be right away
and how much when they when that happens
how much of what they're earning then
gets sent back home we have REM
remittances never get talked about and
how much are they going to start taking
out of the system because inevitably uh
they find ways to leech the system you
you know uh whether it's you know
through the schools or through you know
welfare or food Sams EBT programs and
then another example of just the madness
in New York City and um residents
American citizens being pushed to the
back of the line we had at the beginning
of the school year something like 19,000
illegal alien children entered the
school system and so kids were showing
up to school at city schools and
American citizens were being turned away
from school and we're told very often
that a lot of these kids the only meals
they're getting that they are at school
we're told that all the time they tell
us that all the time and then you had
Laticia James the Attorney General in
New York who's trying to destroy Trump's
life and his business and his entire
family she said that uh New York state
was going to sue school districts that
did not allow the children of illegal
immigrants into the schools now the
thing in New York is New York City
Schools got shut down like March 13th
2020 they were out that whole semester
they were out most of the entire next
year there were policies in place where
if your kid got exposed to co then they
couldn't go to school for two weeks and
there was like some whole testing
regimen which we went through like a
half a dozen times my kid was never in
school it was a disaster so you have all
of these kids in New York a lot of whom
are poor already a lot of whom have
English as a second language who are
already behind they're behind in maths
they're behind in science and reading
and everything already behind now you're
throwing in a bunch of kids who have
made some like ridiculously difficult
trk all through through South America to
get here who are also behind they
haven't been in school and they also
don't speak English so what's going to
happen to the citizens the the citizen
children of New York they're supposed to
inherit this city they're supposed to
like you know keep the lights on keep it
going all night as you know as the the
story of New York goes um and they're
not going to have a chance and the state
is going to make sure they don't have a
chance that's their goal and not to
mention on the school thing the New York
the school officials admitted before the
school started that if you were
basically a migrant child and you were
entering the school system you did not
have to provide proof of immunization
the way that American for anything and
then there's tuberculosis at the border
right what's going on that like why are
we so obsessed with destroying our own
country and destroying our own kids
chance to succeed you know and then
telling immigrants like you don't even
have to be American if the immigrants
who are coming in do not decide to be
American and take up our cultural values
which who even knows knows what they are
at this point then the nation is screwed
look what's going on in France and
Sweden and all of these places the
Visigoths
well here we go again I know Roman
Empire uh uh there is a solution my
friends there is a solution for all of
us is there and that solution's name is
Jen yuger ladies and gentlemen mediaite
reports Jen yuger is so frustrated by
Biden's lagging poll numbers that he
Staffing up for a 2024 run yes Jen yuger
may be the man to say
if he runs and wins the nomination he
will defeat Donald Trump and be our
president actually he won't beat Trump I
doubt he'll win the nomination but I'm
going to say something that will shock
and possibly offend many people I would
vote for Jen yuger if Donald Trump is so
okay hold on on my list on my list of of
cand if if if we have to vote for a
Democrat if your only option was like
Mitt Romney Joe Biden or Jen Yer Jen
yuger all the way if if the domination
uh in the Republican party doesn't go to
Trump Ronda santis is like a begrudging
for me it's like well okay you know like
I well the is is perfectly acceptable
the V is better but if somehow for some
reason you got like a Mike Pence in the
nomination let's say they just arrest
everybody I'd vote for Jake and there's
one reason one he's a buffalo well I
mean call him whatever you want but he's
anti he's he's he's he's he's a he's
he's detrimental to the system to a
certain degree that I'm willing to
accept I don't like his policies I think
his worldview is broken I think he lies
a lot but much
much anything to get rid of the unip
party corporate garbage you know what I
mean and then we'll figure it after the
fact I have advocated I've said the left
they should vote for Donald Trump see I
I uh I I take issue with the anything to
get rid of the the corporate uni party
I'm not that it's a a comment of support
but those idiot uh
commies
commies the magga Communist people they
want to get rid of the uni party they
talk about you know getting rid of black
rock and and while those ideas are good
I do like the idea of having you know
having less corporate power affecting
people's lives and and affecting
legislation and stuff if your option is
you know technocratic fascist
authoritarianism which is what a
communist state would be I still would
rather have the the I would rather have
the status quo than Communists with a
with a a chip in my brain but but I
don't think Jen Huger brings that about
I I mean it may not but he he doesn't he
doesn't do anything to hinder it he
doesn't stop it and he doesn't slow it
down I my my you know I'm looking for ra
ramps Tim yeah I'm I'm just saying like
if it was Mike Pence and Joe
Biden and then there's an option for Jen
yuger with like a reasonable shot to win
I I I could I'd probably be close to
like not voting at all fair however I I
think there is something with Jen that
is that is substantially better than
than the unip party neol neocon
warmongering eat The Bugs World economic
Forum garbage all that stuff the
question is is Jen yuger in line with
these World economic Forum views climate
change Etc that being the case that's
where you're run into okay this is why
we can't vote for this guy he's too much
in line with these negatives yeah anyone
that's anyone that is believes in the
the predictions of the climate change
alarmists they are they're whether they
intend it or not they would fall into
the group of people that would end up
you know destroying the world to sa
occupying Kevin McCarthy's office today
yeah exactly I mean those people would
destroy Humanity to save the world
that's what they would they would say
they would do my view is like the left
hates Donald Trump yeah they say all
these things about him a lot of these
things are wrong but Trump shatters the
unip party he he freaks them out he C he
SWS Discord within this machine that the
left also hates so I my attitude was
like if you've got Trump or Biden the
left should be voting for Donald Trump
because Trump destabilizes the corporate
uni party and you're not getting
somebody you want but you are causing
damage to the Empire to the cathedral y
so that's why I like Trump trump happens
to align more so with My Views I've
agree with a lot of decisions he's taken
I think he's got his faults Jen yuger
doesn't but as much as I don't like his
views I think in not the same way I
think Trump is better Jen is an outsider
smashing into the corporate uni party he
tries to be involved they hate his guts
they smeared him they made up lies about
him and then he got mad now he's trying
to run I'm not saying it's a perfect
scenario I'm just saying look man you
know may maybe I made the mistake with
AOC that's for sure I said she's better
than the unip party establishment people
I think that's probably the case in some
some ways and it's hard to know because
Crowley who she defeated back in was it
2018 we've not seen what he would have
done with Co and everything
I think is awful but I still kind of
believe she's probably better than
Crowley would have been cuz Crowley is
unip party corporate lib March and
lockstep at the very least AOC teams up
with Matt gates to get to stop insider
trading in Congress and she's also easy
to make a fool of well there you go I
guess like I'm looking for I'm looking
for wins I'm not I'm more reformer than
revolutionary I'm trying to I hope we
don't have Civil War I hope we don't
fall into Mass conflict but look man
you've got angry people in this country
it's not going to be solved by whatever
the corporate uni party is doing that
being said Jen is not going to be
president he's not going to be the
nominee and it's not a it's not a real
circumstance where anyone would vote for
him but but if he was elected we'd have
really angry horses we can count on that
for sure no you'd have very happy horses
happy okay happy horse very very happy
yeah he'll never live that one down dude
so check check this out do you guys
remember this and look I'm trying I'm I
I uh uh I try to give Jen as much uh uh
credit as I can and and and for that
don't know who he is I assume everybody
did that's why he's the host and founder
of The Young Turks very popular
prominent Progressive uh uh news and
commentary on social media used to be
MSNBC so's he's a prominent guy he's got
he's got millions of followers not
popular with Armenians no certainly not
certainly not and he doesn't want to
drop that name The Young Turks which
basically is akin to saying the Hitler
Youth but yeah we have this from CNN
they say Sanders retracts endorsement of
controversial Congressional candidate
this is crazy Bernie Sanders withdrew
his endorsement of Jen yuger after push
back from supporters over huger's
previous controversial comments as well
as his decision not to accept
endorsements so even Bernie was like
yeah we're not going to endorse this guy
jenss got this video that that that he's
not going to live down and I I is it's
it's it's a silly video but we have to
bring it up because it matters from 10
years ago I think where he talks about
how if he's if he was the benevolent
dictator of the world he would legalize
giving pleasure to animals abruptly
that's just so weird abruptly and for no
reason he says it his crew starts
laughing and he's like well how did we
get here look my point is and it's like
maybe this guy shouldn't be president
maybe may maybe right so so I guess I'll
say this when it comes to a Jen yuger
type as president my more to the point
is I'm not making a substantive claim
over who he is and what he would do it's
more so the idea of any Outsider is
better than the corporate establishment
garbage upon closer inspection I got to
say man like I don't know how you escape
having said something like that well my
question immediately is after he said
something like that my question is
what's putting this in your is this
something that you are doing in your
spare time are you pleasuring your
animals this man's hard drive what is
going on or even not the you know like
there was that guy that was was he like
a upen professor or something or pen
State went the woods with his dog he was
going out in the woods with his dog and
then and then I engaging in love making
with his dog and then someone there
there was a there was a a trail camera
filling it he was filming it himself and
there was he no I thought there was a
trail camera that filmed him was it and
it was over a period of years they there
there was a trail camera installed that
caught him yeah but I I you know look I
don't care it's it's it's messed up
stuff don't do it right that's that's
really disgusting but I'm sorry man I
don't see Jen yuger being president
because the moment he runs that is the
only thing Republicans will run and it
will be massively damaging to Democrats
across the board yeah I I'll say right
now the fact that Jen yuger says he has
to run against Biden because Biden will
lose and he's got the best chance or
he's got he's he's no one else will do
it I think you're already going to see
attack ads where they played this video
of Jen Huger advocating abruptly and
without prompt yeah no problem for
giving pleasure to horses
yeah it's just I'm sorry man I I don't I
I I don't like bringing this stuff up
because it's like it doesn't get to the
substance of a progressive argument no
but in terms of in terms of politics
he's going to be asked on a debate stage
Mr yuger you've previously stated that
you want to legalize the act of giving
giving animal sexual gratification where
do you stand on this now and he's never
going to live that down no no and I nor
should he really I mean he did say that
on camera live for no apparent reason no
one asked him other than it was in his
mind and if it was in his mind at that
moment when you think weird things like
a lot of times you don't say the weird
things you think unless you keep
thinking them they've been normalized in
your own head the worst thing I've said
without prompt is that I would consider
voting for Jen yuger I was pretty weird
yeah I don't know if you're going to
live that down I think we should well no
but but I can clarify my point is
basically I despise the corporate
warmongering establishment so much that
I I'll tell I'll tell you one thing I
believe Jen yuger would save Julian
Assange yeah and there's things okay
there you go thank you very
much app but that's basically like what
I mean sort of I don't think he would be
good for this country I don't think his
policies make sense I think he is
woefully ignorant on many many issues
and the Animals things really gross I'm
just saying it it's it says a lot to
everybody listening considering what he
said that I think he would still
probably be a better option than say
like Joe Biden Hillary Clinton or Mitt
Romney because I think these people are
like the Apex of evil well Mitt Romney
is a Jen yuger would not give us World
War I I don't think none of the people
that you list to are are going to have a
different Outlook than and Jen on
climate change that's and that's true
but I don't think Jen Huger goes to war
yep and I think he he pardons julan
Assange I think there's a lot of there's
certain overlapping victories we get I
think he he would he would push for
things like no insider trading in
Congress and and and if if if you don't
trust the guy if only because his base
wants these things like it's it's
important to point out like I really do
think the the the pardoning and
restoring of Julian Assange is is
extremely extremely important because
what people need to understand and and
and Julian needs to be in the news more
he's not in the news enough but it's
hard because it's like you can only say
the story so many times the US
government took it upon itself to arrest
and detain a non-citizen for the act of
Journalism and then basically lock him
up for going on you know more than a
decade we can't allow a standard like
that to exist right yep so there there's
a lot that I'd be willing to accept if
it like gave us certain ground you know
but I got to say man the if you haven't
seen the video of J talking about horses
I'm sorry dude but you're never living
that one down it's it's just like he
says if I was the benevolent dictator I
would Legalize leing It Down and it's
just like name me name man it's just
weird that I'm imagining this guy
getting elected and he's sitting down in
the Oval Office and then he's like and
then his advisor is like what's your
first order of business sir and is like
signing an executive order that you can
you know I keep it family friendly but
you know what I'm saying like crazy
person leave your animals very excited
like what are you doing why are you it's
crazy con by the way well and he ran for
congress too and I'm kind of worried
about what he's going what he's going to
propose you know I and it's just you
know I don't know whatever you get the
point congratulations he'll run we'll
see what happens the Assange thing is
like what Russia is doing with that Wall
Street Journal journalist who still
locked up but he was in their country
yeah the
US used an international Network to
apprehend Julian Assange on false rape
charges yeah I shouldn't even say rape
they weren't even rape charges it was it
was a false assault no it was um it was
like a lesser sexual assault charge
based on like a a ripped condom or
something and uh the women apparently
said why is he being arrested this is
not what we asked for the women were
were trying to get it like an STD test
or something it was like a consentual
encounter where the woman got concerned
about her health and wanted him to get
tested and asked the police could he be
compelled and then they immediately ran
and arrested him he was in the UK he
then says this is a trick and it was a
trick because they dropped the case and
said there was never a case in the first
place but then the US said do not
release him and they they kept him and
then they raided and arrested him so uh
yeah anybody who's going to start fixing
some of that stuff that's that's creepy
horrible evil stuff and uh I guess you
take the horse guy over over Joe Biden
you know what I mean do you think
honestly that let's just say any let's
say it was Trump or RFK they actually
wanted to do it they really wanted to
rescue and release and and in a way
rescue Julian Assan Trump wouldn't do it
okay say let's say R let's say RFK
ordered it well we saw what happened
when Trump ordered a a TR a troop
withdrawal from Syria and they just no
do you think that they really like the
Deep State you know the swamp would
allow it yes they would yeah there's a
big difference between withdrawing our
troops from Syria and letting a guy to
jail when they what they did with Trump
and the Syrian troops is they lied and
said they was done and how do you check
you know what I mean you get the
paperwork and since it's done you're
like okay good with Julian Assan you're
going to be like okay bring him to my
office MH and they're going to be like
uh well he went to Kentucky ucky it's
like well then go get him yeah go get
him that's yep MH so it's a lot harder
but man yeah uh I do hope that if Donald
Trump gets elected Ross
alri uh uh Julian Assange and um Edward
Snowden are are parted or receive
commutations there there's probably a
whole bunch more people who are
deserving as well uh Edward Snowden I'm
not the biggest fan of but I do think
it's time he comes home and just lives a
normal life I don't think he should go
rot in jail for what he did but he's
there's a huge difference between
Assange and Snowden Shane can't run he
was born in Istanbul yeah what he was
born in Istanbul Turkey oh immigrated
with his family when he was when he was
eight he wasn't born to like military
parents or something
um that's no it says immigrated no so
then he can't I don't so I don't know
what then what is this fake news I have
no idea that is fake news someone
pointed that out on Twitter thank you
very much uh who is it it's uh that yeah
look at this like he he sat down and did
an interview where he talked about he
might have to do it cuz no one else will
so what you can't man so this is just
him lying that's like the people who are
saying I got a book coming out it's just
a play for the
book I'm sorry dude these people are
evil that sucks yeah unless he's going
to come out and be like no actually his
mom's American or something but even if
your mom's American like if you're born
out of the country yeah there's there's
rules about that yeah I don't think you
can't be even franch American although
wasn't wasn't John McCain born in Panama
but he was born he was born on a on a
Bas ter that's different he was born on
who was John mcain right right right
right but he's American yeah yes yeah I
mean like your parents are American
you're American i i i VI was talking
about 14th Amendment stuff he's
completely right do where where do you
stand on that on the birthright
citizenship stuff uh it needs to be
ended immediately it's it's it's fake
it's like a fake interpretation it's not
what anyone anyone meant when when they
when they drafted the birthright
citizenship right the idea that Chinese
Nationals will artificially inate will
get a surrogate mother in in California
who then gives birth to a a CH to a
Chinese child Chinese Nationals that has
American citizenship it's like come on
man we are being exploited here yeah we
are definitely being exploited there's
very few countries that have uh
Birthright citizenship I think Brazil is
one most European countries do not have
that including France which of course is
leading to some big problems there that
they have um but the US is one of the
only ones in the country I think there's
like four or five I think that the the I
didn't know know about the argument
against uh the or or the argument
against Birthright citizenships the way
that that the V laid it out until last
night I wasn't aware like I I just had
never heard that argument before I'd
heard people talk about the 14th
Amendment i' hadd never heard anyone
explain it and I never went and did the
research myself to figure out exactly
the details and stuff and to be honest
with you it is compelling you know if
you are here illegally then you know if
and you're born to parents that are here
illegally then you're not subject to all
the the the laws of the United States
you don't have you're not supposed to be
able to get a job you know you're not
you're not supposed to be paying taxes
you're illegal that's what that's what
that whole DACA thing is about so you
know to me it's compelling and I I also
like if you I mean that's sort of why if
you're deporting entire families that's
one thing but like if you are allowing
illegal immigrants to stay and then they
go all the way through high school and
discover that they have no absolutely no
status that's really bad yeah that's
really dangerous you know and we're not
doing anything to rebuild or to like
help stabilize the countries that are
sending people you know which I don't
think we have much of an obligation to
do outside of the Americas even at all
but in the Americas you had kamla Harris
who was supposed to be the um borders
are and then she was like no no I'm not
the borders are I'm actually just
dealing with these Northern triangle
countries um and the idea and then they
started sending all of these messages
like don't come now we're going to help
you we're going to bring in American
corporations to create jobs and all that
stuff and they didn't do any of that
they just didn't they just didn't do it
she shed her responsibility at the
border she shed her responsibility with
regard to the thing that her staff said
was her job um and nothing's going on
there so you also have the people who
are the most entrepreneurial leaving
those countries and coming here which is
going to further destabilize those
Nations the people that the people that
are leaving their home country are
probably the ones that should be staying
there because they're likely the ones
that are most capable to help fix their
own countries again if you look at the
people coming across the border in the
South it's it's not mostly families it's
mostly young young men and to be honest
with you if I understand correctly like
the people that are coming from South
America it's not it's not like 95%
people from South America there are
people coming from all over the world
there's a lot of like Africa and stuff
I've heard heard stories of Chinese
chines yeah and that means it's a
security issue China is is is is
unquestionably our biggest rival in the
world right that's the biggest the
biggest geopolitical rival we have is
China if there are Chinese Nationals
coming in you don't know if they're if
they're actually trying to escape China
or if they're coming here as uh you know
for for for um industrial Espionage or
whatever but there is industrial
Espionage going on that we that the
government has a responsibility to
protect American companies from and and
if they're abating their responsibility
and they have for you know the better
part of the past decade at least
probably longer so we had Michael Yan on
recently on Infowars on the Alex Jones
Show and he um he is one of the best uh
reporters period especially on conflict
I saw some of his I think Daren Gap
stuff yes he spent a lot of time at the
Darian Gap and the Darion is of course
where so many are coming through on
their way to the us and that gets no
coverage from the US media at all but um
he's very familiar with uh with the
situation down there and he brought uh
Chinese interpreters down with him uh
that spoke multiple Chinese dialects and
he said that it was his opinion based on
the people that they talked to that a
lot of the Chinese coming through were
military or were uh connected with the
Chinese government um just based on
their the way they communicated the way
that they were dressed the way that they
were um behaving in many ways and so his
opinion was that many coming through
that are Chinese are our military coming
into the US that's not good that's not a
good situation at all I was seeing um
some reporting from I I think real
America's voice the other day and they
were down they were like down somewhere
I don't remember where it was cuz I'm
not super familiar with that geography
but they counted like I think a hundred
boats coming through that pass going
north in just an hour it was like these
long skinny boats and they would like
yell out where are you from where you
from and it was a lot of Africa it was a
lot of Venezuela and we kind of helped
destroy Venezuela you know what I mean
and now we're going to try and do the
same thing to Brazil yeah the vast
majority that have been coming through
Eagle Pass are coming from Venezuela
well Venezuela destroyed itself Maduro
and and Chavez had a lot to do with sure
you know yeah we had our our reporter we
have a correspondent that works at the
border on the Mexican side he lives in
Mexico and a few days before Eagle Pass
really popped off his his report that he
dropped was that hundreds were arriving
on top of the trains as we now know the
Beast the Beast and that's been going on
for a long time but this was a new surge
a new rush and uh he said the vast
majority of them his estimate was 90%
were Venezuelans uh many of them are
families coming with children now and
they're riding on top of these trains
and arriving by the thousands now and
pouring into Eagle Pass and of course
other Crossings of I uh you know I've
always opposed colonization you know
these these Colonials we can't uh we
can't have that you know what I mean
coming here and settling on lands where
you're not welcome that's colonization
bringing their blankets with
tuberculosis on them oh man let's jump
to the story from the post millennial
cases I think it was now we have more
than that over the we got the story for
the post-millennial Biden thanks to
santis for saying Trump is to blame for
inflation desus gains little from
bashing the front runner for the
Republican nomination Biden gains
everything so we saw this last night
it's an article by Libby Emmons I had
fun writing why don't you talk I I had
fun writing this one uh I said it all in
the article yeah so I jack soic and I
were talking about this this morning
because he put out this tweet and he was
the one who showed me that uh Biden
sharing this clip of DeSantis last
tonight at the debate um Biden using
basically what dantis said as a campaign
uh a campaign ad so you have Des santis
go out there he's bashing Trump trump
should be here on the stage you know
basically just insulted that Trump isn't
there to take him seriously and blame
Republicans for the inflation blame
Republicans for inflation blamed Trump
for inflation said that Trump adding 7.8
trillion dollars to the national debt
while he was in office is what leads to
inflation now well you know when Trump
left office inflation was at
1.4% by December 2022 it was I think at
6.5 right now it's at like
3.67 so Biden is saying oh it's better
than it was but it's only better than it
was after he jacked it up ridiculously
and it's still twice as high as it was
when Trump was in office and the
national debt like adding if you scroll
down you could see the numbers of the
national debt like there's large numbers
uh Trump brought the national debt up to
like 32 trillion something up from 30 2
trillion something now it's over 33
trillion so you know and it's also hard
to get these numbers like I was digging
around trying to find the national debt
numbers and it's like just these
continuous clicking clocks of money just
getting spent constantly this this math
doesn't add up Trump does it not add up
no it doesn't Trump added 7.8 trillion
uhhuh bringing the national debt to 32.5
trillion from 32.5
trillion
uh
32.5 3 four
324 those are billions yeah so the
that's my screw up I apologize the
numbers are so large that also failed at
helping but I I would like to say first
and foremost Donald Trump has some
responsibility for inflation that's a
fact uh however when it came to this
spending it was not just Donald Trump
who did it it was all of Congress it was
Governors and basically everybody but a
small handful of people like Thomas
Massie were in favor of this massive
spending because the co crisis that
being said if you uh there was an
economic chart we pulled up a long time
ago I know it's been a while you can
find it the moment Joe Biden starts
signing executive orders we see a
massive explosion in inflation and a
decrease in wages and so this is you
there you can look at the the the uh the
charts tracking inflation Biden gets
elected it's fine Biden signs a bunch of
executive orders it starts skyrocketing
whatever it is he was reversing and
changed at a bigger impact on just the
debt Ronda santis it was a gaff to come
out and accuse Donald Trump of simply
because of the debt it's his fault he's
so desperate to throw tomatoes at Trump
that he's fueling Joe Biden's talking
points don't do it man it's just it's
not even that strong of a talking
point yes that's correct well there you
go but also you know this is going to be
a Biden campaign ad and you know it's
going to come out of the White House and
it's going to be on the debate stage
when Biden and Trump face off again um
yeah and also you know the amount of the
national debt is that Biden is spending
is more than Trump and I think Obama
combined you know as well as his number
of executive orders is more than Trump
so it is pretty shocking that this is
what they're doing and they're doing it
because they can't stand that they don't
have a shot against this
man well the money supply is decreasing
tremendously and
rapidly y'all y'all are going to be in
for a wild ride man if you look at this
one let me see can I make this more
visible this is the M1 money stock this
is the this is like this is the billions
of dollars in circulation and you can
see around Co it went it went up a lot
well this is because they turned savings
accounts into checking accounts yeah
which is insane and then after that it
just keeps going up and up and then it
starts dropping precipitously not a good
thing to just turn around no yeah none
of this is good skyrocketing up and then
and then starting to it's almost the
worst thing you could do in the
situation instability is the problem but
uh you know thanks Joe Biden you know I
don't do much shopping at Brick and
mortars besides the grocery store but
when I visit my grandmother she likes to
go out and take me to buy a shirt or
something like that and we went to uh
she lives in Miami went to a Ross the
other day and we walked in and the line
was 50 people deep whoa in on the middle
of a week day a there's no one there
there's no one working no one working
that's definitely fair um but the amount
of people that were there purchasing and
were intent on Pur purchasing cuz they
didn't mind waiting in line was insane
so we went next door to TJ Maxx instead
the line was even longer and so we said
not even going to deal with it we'll go
to the mall tomorrow and so we did and
the mall was just packed with people
buying stuff and she said and she's very
intuitive about this stuff she said
everybody's using credit cards I said
absolutely Y and people are shopping
like drunken Sailors even though there's
just no way that they're you know
funding this uh in a manner that they
can that is sustainable for them or for
the economy I mean it's what American
credit card debt just passed a trillion
dollars for the first time like last
month right yeah it's really bad I don't
see how Biden wins the economy is in a
weird place like the numbers are all
over the place yeah weird because you've
got some metrics that seemingly are good
giving the Press an open door to be like
look how great the economy is meanwhile
regular people can't buy groceries and
so you're getting conflicting messages
the you you got one person saying no no
these numbers are good these are bad I'm
not a finance guy it's in a weird place
people are struggling and living pay pay
to paycheck and credit card debt is
through the roof student loans are
probably going to implode soon Joe Biden
can't think straight Democrats don't
like
him how does this guy run he's got to
drop out I don't well that's what Nome
is is here for I predict it now or what
that I mean I don't think that the
average person again we I talked about
um you know luxury beliefs earlier today
I think the average person is detached
from the problems you know if they're
not directly affecting them I don't
think that they they they believe that
the problems are real for other people
and I think that if you if that people
tend to put their head in the sand and
try to hide from the problems as much as
they can people don't want to hear oh
this is bad people don't want to hear oh
that's bad and I really think that
people will say well if we just vote for
the people that say they're going to
make it nice and we don't vote for the
bad people then it'll be okay the the
American the average American that
doesn't pay close attention to you know
alternative news or anything that pays
attention to regular news they truly
believe and they're fed the same
propaganda all the time that the quote
unquote deplorables are actually a major
threat to the United States that the the
deplorables and and Donald Trump or or
Republicans because it doesn't matter
that it's Trump like as much as people
will will glob on to Trump and say he's
the guy it doesn't matter that it's
Trump it's someone that has an agenda
that is opposed to The Establishment so
if it were V to get into the position of
running they would slime V in the exact
same way that they've slimed Donald
Trump it probably wouldn't stick as well
because a is a different guy but still
they would use all of the same well
they've been planning they've been doing
that with Des sanus right like as soon
as the STIs says anything they're like
oh he's a white supremacist yeah they
were there are Nazis in Florida yeah and
so that's to Santa's fault yes yeah and
and meanwhile a bunch of those guys came
down from Maine from what I understand
yeah um but yeah that's they are going
to smear disantis and so that what that
ended up doing was it took that whole
desantis's more electable argument and
it sort of showed that to be false
because whoever is put out on the GOP
stage is going to be painted with the
broad brush of you know anti-Semitism
homophobia transphobia and white
supremacy and privilege and the average
person that wants the drama to stop
doesn't realize that the drama is
created by the left for a reason there
were tons of people say oh it's it was
Donald Trump or whatever but it's
dialectics it is a dialectical movement
created by the left the left creates the
problem then they offer the solution
that moves the society to in the
direction that they want liberalism
doesn't do that yeah I mean it's it's
pretty interesting too because I was
watching The Bill O'Reilly Tucker
Carlson interview on on X and I was
telling you guys about it before the
show it was really fascinating to watch
because these are two guys who have been
doing news from a conservative Network
for years both of whom lost their jobs
at that Network because they you know we
don't know why Bill Riley lost his job
but because they seem to have gone too
far or whatever and have ended up
migrating to Independent Media so they
were talking about Independent Media
which was fascinating because you know
here we are we do Independent Media um
but they were also talking about how we
are in an age of like Discord yeah how
we're in an age where things are getting
all screwed up um and that you have the
progressive left is eded with the Press
so the Press is pushing all of this
stuff and regular Americans who don't
tend to you know believe that they're
being lied to necessarily are looking at
this and saying like oh I'm going to
believe the New York Times And The
Washington Post and NPR just like an NBC
and CBS just like I always did and
suddenly these things are actually not
telling you the truth I was on a BBC
Radio Show the other day and we were
talking about free speech and freedom of
the press and it was like as regards
Russell Brand because they're super
obsessed with Russell Brand in the UK
and I'm just super obsessed with free
speech um and so we were talking about
it and they were like it's so important
we were talking about how that group of
MPS who they were very clear to tell me
was not the British government I was
like it's a group of MPS yeah like
they're MPS they're in your Parliament
right like if they're in your Parliament
that's the government like that is the
government like it doesn't have to be
rishy sunak necessarily like going out
there and doing it so we're talking
about the letter that got written to um
streaming platforms to say hey are you
going to demonetize Russell Brand just
like YouTube did and they were saying oh
their argument is that they weren't
telling them to demonetize and it's like
oh sure you know honey would you like to
W wipe the chocolate off of your face or
do you want to just leave it there it's
like oh Mom I'm G to wipe it off my face
you know so it's very clear that I think
they were telling them to demonetize
Russell Brand and to start violating
Free Speech Norms um but what the other
journalists were telling me the prim
these British journalists were that
someone needs to be in charge someone
needs to determine what's misinformation
and I was like who should be in charge
you guys should you guys be in charge
because as soon as like someone who
disagrees with you is in charge they're
going to start saying that everything
you believe is true is fake so you're
you're not first of all you're not
thinking long term here second of all
it's just this incessant belief in the
expert class y of people who what went
to the right schools and the right
schools have be clowned themselves and
don't even have you know are not even
worth the degrees that they're giving
out anymore so I think there really is
um there really needs to be sort of a
cultural Awakening and people need to
realize that the Press is in bed with
the progressive left they're telling you
what they want you to think so that they
can continue to destroy society and try
and remake it in different way I'm going
to mention it again the smithm
modernization act of 2012 made it legal
for the federal government the United
States federal government to produce
propaganda for dissemination in the
United States states that happened at
the same time that the smartphone
reached Market saturation so everybody
had the internet in their pocket the
most powerful mind control device ever
devised was built into your smartphone
the like button will make people behave
in crazy ways everybody that listens to
the mainstream media the corporate media
and gets their news from it you are all
being
propagandized let's jump to the uh
economic stuff cuz we got this story out
of the Daily Mail Fool's Gold expert
questions whether Costco's
$1,945 1 o gold bars are really a good
deal is Shoppers rush to snap them up
amid rampant inflation and bank failures
I'm a gold bug so I say yes so uh Costco
started selling gold bars customers can
buy two per shopping session or whatever
you'd call it and they sold out and uh
uh what I heard was people are buying
them because they're getting cash back
on their credit cards and that 2%
that's money you then sell it at at a at
a smaller loss or something like you can
sell it for a 1% loss but you make 2%
off the credit cards that's what people
are doing but a lot of people are just
point flat out saying they want gold
right now because the economy is going
to implode so I I don't whatever the
reason may be when you hear that there's
a run on gold among regular people
that's scary I'm kind of worried about
that now I got to say I have silver I
have gold I have crypto I am not worried
in the sense that I will be done harm
because I already bought gold I'm going
to be worried about what the other
people are going to do when they can't
get any when yeah that's scary you know
what I mean like you can't get it
they're running out there there are
there are other things for that well I'm
not I I depending on the degree of
conflict this country faces depending on
how bad things get people misunderstand
what the value of gold is the value of
gold is a hard asset that is not being
replicated it's it's hard to produce so
it retains its value however Gold's been
floating around this the same price for
quite a while it's just like you know
you if you're living in the United
States it's good to have gold it's it's
good to hedge your bets against the US
dollar all all that stuff because gold
is worth something right but in the
event of like a total social breakdown I
got I'm sorry like what are you going to
do with gold that was what I was
thinking too you're going to bring your
gold your 1 o gold bar for two grand to
a burger shop and be like can you make
change meanwhile nobody's going to be at
the Burger Shop no one will be working
at the Burger Shop no I mean I think
there will be uh just because social
order breaks down doesn't mean there's
not going to be business there's so
there was a blackout in New York City in
2003 uh and it was the like one of the
substations sort of blew up and we could
all see like the smoke coming up and um
and the you know all the lights went out
down town and everyone's like oh my God
it's 911 except it's 2003 now and uh
we're wagging around I had my paycheck
because we all got evacuated from our
building CU there was no lights on and I
just very quietly like took my paycheck
out of the drawer which eventually
actually I got fired but um yeah cuz I
took my pay and I didn't give anybody
else their pay I was just like I'm not
leaving payday tomorrow I have all the
checks I'm just taking mine oh well
anyway but so what you couldn't get
McDonald's what no it wasn't that I
couldn't get McDonald's it was that I
had trouble cashing my check oh of
course so I went to a check cashing
place and there was a guy in the dark
with candles and a shotgun and he cashed
my check right and and people need to
understand you look at videos out of
Syria during the Civil War and there are
people walking to and from work carrying
food and groc
however you're not going to carry a gold
bar into a McDonald's and be like yall
take a number one uh super siiz the
fries and give me a bunch of uh sweet
and sour sauce and here's one $2,000
gold bar can you can you break that for
me they're going to be like no yeah they
might be taking gold that's true silver
coins silver coins so if you uh so I'm
not going to tell anybody what to buy
but what I would buy they have uh
websites where you can buy American
silver coins like actual dimes nickels
quarters and bags of them and they they
like they actually represent the silver
value of them so if you're if you're
trading with something but I got to be
honest man when we started trading gold
and silver it was because it was hard
enough to get but easy enough to get
silver like aluminum was worth more than
silver it was just like is it real
silver okay we'll trade with it basing
the the value of the currency on silver
is was the is the same thing it's it's
no different than putting a serial
number on a dollar bill basically
letting you know it was
real in the event of an actual social
breakdown you know what's you know Phil
knows what's going to happen what are
you going to buy a cheeseburger with you
you want you want to buy a a two number
ones for you and your girl and you go to
McDonald's what's the currenc that
they're going to take I can't say on
[Laughter]
YouTube what yeah you can I'll say it
it's bullets yeah but listen listen
currently you can still buy body armor
night vision is King get guns and ammo
night vision people really don't people
need to know this the what there's two
things that make the American so
dangerous air superiority is number one
and I I could be wrong but night vision
is a major the night yep I think night
vision might be number two the thing the
thing people don't realize that if if
you if you want to you can get night
vision and you can equip stuff so that
way you have infrared lights on your
gear and you can see everything and it
is black as night for anyone that
doesn't have night vision like
absolutely no lights that no one can see
any light on you and you are looking
around like it's daytime it's it's it's
crazy I got and and real night vision
not the stuff you get on like Amazon
where it's like a camera that just you
know to be to be fair these lowgrade
Bargain Bin $100 infrared cameras can
help you see at night so hey no beef
legit legit military T night vision well
where did you get something like that
you can get them from tnvc tvc.com the
what and if you want to get the good
military ones they're PVS 31s they're
dual tubes um you can see satellites yep
no way you look in the sky and you see
satellites and it's just like wow what
does that go for $113,000 was the one
that I got fairly cost prohibitive for
the maybe maybe once some other people
get their fifth gold record they can
seven gold bars you can get get a you
can get a PVS 31 which is a single tube
so the mine mine are dual tubes but you
can get a single tube for somewhere
around $3,000 so it's like you know it's
expensive but it's something that the
average person can afford and just one
eye yeah one eye and and that is still
way better than nothing hunting hunting
it's great yeah it's crazy and again and
I'll say it again body armor you can get
you can still buy body armor there are
politicians that are looking to make
these things illegal so if you can
get it if you can get this stuff if you
can afford it it's not a bad idea to get
it now do you have a do you know what FR
is no it's a I forgot what company is uh
Safe Life or something a flexible rifle
armor system oh so it's it's a hexagonal
ceramic plates whereas your typical
ceramic plate can withstand only one
about one or two rounds typically one
they this what they train us on they say
one round and you're and if you get hit
like your armor is no good the ceramic
stuff because they're all separate
plates they actually can withstand a bit
more still you don't want to get shot so
we
avoiding those things there's a company
called Hesco that I that I uh saw some
stuff that has come back from Ukraine
recently uh they were advertising and
they were taking full 762 by 31 or 762 x
51 which is uh 308 rounds NATO U big
bullets very fast and they're you know
they're defeating armor is getting
impressive armor is impressive yeah it's
crazy and again it is available now and
there are people that want there are
politicians that want to make that stuff
ille so I'm just I'm wondering uh the
extent to which people think the
collapse is happening right so obviously
we talk about Civil War but Civil War we
talk about this wide perspective which
could be it's a cultural battle where
people are being arrested and imprisoned
so there is physical violence but it's
not like armies marching but maybe the
high-end extreme P version of that is it
does get to like a total social
breakdown I don't know which way it goes
I'm wondering what the average person
thinks because these people who are
buying up this gold like crazy ain't
listening to this show some of them are
for sure but we're talking about Costco
selling out gold bars that's way bigger
than anything we can do or influence so
regular people are looking at something
and being like I got to buy gold yeah
that's kind of worrying to me yeah
confidence breaking down in the system I
bet it's the flash
mobs there's also like a ton of gold
advertising on alternative media like
real America's voice recently I feel
like that's always a thing though but
listen listen look look compies look at
you look at some of this like this this
lady right here
y I don't think this lady and I'm and
I'm and I'm not trying to be
discriminatory here based on what she
looks like or anything like that but I I
would be willing to bet it is not that
likely that she's listening to Infowars
Tim cast stepen Crowder or whatever
whoever else has got gold commercials
Ben Shapiro I have a really good friend
who I've had since College uh who is
very Lefty very liberal she's
open-minded though I mean she's not like
one of these people who's just like I
can't talk to you she's buying up gold
like nuts she has been for a couple of
years wow mhm you know you know who else
has and she has like a good job and
money and you know who else is buying
lots of gold she's also started a China
yeah really China's opened a whole bunch
of these we buy Golds throughout the
United States she's also started
planting her own food she's like getting
kind of freaked out you and she's a
total Normy I mean she's not exactly
totally Normy because she's my friend
she's kind of weirdo but like compared
to me she's sort of normal another thing
is people don't realize that like
outside of the United States if you go
to Saudi Arabia if you're in in the
Middle East there are vending machines
that you can buy gold bars in wow you
know like vending machines vending
machines you they'll be like whether
they're like tiny you know tenth of an
ounce or whatever ATM but uh well I mean
I don't know I I I assume I don't know
what they're what they're like I've Got
Friends yeah I've got friends that have
gone over and told me they're like and
my friend has bought actual gold from
the vending machines it is normal to
consider gold a store of value outside
of the US America were so used to you
know just looking at dollar the dollar
exactly but other countries and and
other societies where the value of
currency sometimes fluctuates or has
gone crazy and stuff and also in the
Middle East they've always been very
interested in tangible assets and stuff
like that if I understand correctly so
it's not strange to be like yo I'm going
to get gold and another thing people
think when I buy gold it's like I'm
going to buy gold and then I'm like oh
I'm out of the money it's when you buy
gold you're not out of the money yeah
just you just have it's like putting it
into it's like putting into a really
safe Bank what about diamonds do
diamonds have value personally I don't
like Jews I don't think diamonds have
any value right like haven't people
stopped buying diamonds because well
they they're manufactured now so it's
like there's just no I mean I'm not
telling anyone what they should or
should not buy personally I this is the
things that have been valuable over the
years this is the thing that uh you know
I didn't learn when you're living
paycheck to paycheck you are outside of
this system when you are making more
money than you need per paycheck all of
a sudden the money you spend never
leaves so like you start making more
money and you start building up a
savings now you've got a savings sit in
your bank account money doesn't leave
let's say you decide to buy something so
you buy a car car has value now you
still retain the value of your assets
whereas for most people they're renting
they're they're uh they have a lease on
a car or something like that if they do
have one or they're not they're using
Uber all their money is being sucked
away from them they can't build wealth
and that's of course the objective yes
that you owe nothing and you will be
happy but also the cbdc where it's
programmable and they can just turn it
off or they can say if you don't spend
it in 30 days it disappears yep so
that's the and if they if they make if
you get a cbdc don't think you're going
to be allowed to buy gold like if you
get once they have body C the EBT card
you can't buy beer with it exactly they
they will be able to progam can't buy
hot food what you can't buy hot food
yeah at the store yeah it can't be
prepared yeah so you you won't be able
to buy anything that has actual value
they will not allow you to take your
cbdc they won't let you build wealth
exactly and that is going to be built
into the system like it's not some it's
not going to be an option nowadays as
long as there's cash you can still go
and buy you know whether whether even if
it's just you know even if it's uh
silver coins dimes and and quarters and
half dollars from pre-1964 they're
that's where the silver that's when they
stopped using silver in coins in the US
um those are still available you can get
them with dollars as as soon as there's
a cbdc all that's all that's done that's
off the table and just like you said
you're not going to be able to buy armor
you're not going to be able to buy ammo
you're not going to be able to buy guns
if they don't want you to buy guns maybe
you'll be able to buy certain guns
they'll have certain guns that have
probably some kind of micro stamping or
something like that but it's all all of
the the direction that we're heading in
is all about control it's all top- down
control and you know I know there are
people that are watching this that are
like yeah we know we're on the same page
we've been listening to this forever and
ever
but the average person starting to buy
gold means that people that are not
plugged into this type of world they're
not you know they're they're starting to
smell the bad smell of top- down control
and it's something that people need to
pay attention to and going and going to
that point and then also what you were
saying at the beginning of the broadcast
about people need to get away from these
hot zones these danger zones um I'm I'm
seeing that and what you were saying
about your friend I'm seeing the normies
start to wake up I'm seeing them people
I know who I never would have thought
would be tapped into this sense of
urgency that that a lot of us have had
for many years and that's why we do what
we do that's why you're here in you know
this part of the country with your
studio and not in where you were before
um that's why you know you've moved
around I've moved around this sense of
urgency saying you know right now we
still have that ability to to relocate
to find that place that we feel like is
best for us um to ride out the storm so
to speak and I'm seeing the normies are
starting to pick up on that too people
that I know does that mean that it's too
late no I don't think so I don't think
it's too late at all I think it's it's
it's there's still time it's still
there's still time to like save the
Republic oh I mean there's still time oh
no no the Republic's dead but you not to
late I was like yeah yeah the Republic I
think the Republic will be uh what I
really want is a cow we'll win I think
we'll win or maybe like a sheep get all
of them man I can't get all of them so
one of the roosters escaped the other
day and so when I ride my bike up to the
studio and I'm coming in in the morning
I see this this dumb little mother ring
around the yard by himself and I'm like
he'll be fine he's a rooster whatever I
go in and then I'm in the studio and
then I record my first segment I go over
the window and I look and there's
walking around the yard and I'm like so
I went down and I walked over and I
opened the little little gate cuz
there's an outside portion inside and he
ran inside and then you know he went and
do his chicken chicken business but you
know these things are I love chickens
they're hilarious keep them away from
pretty ridiculous oh no wow that been 10
years I didn't need that visual though
Wow Let's uh I want to talk about the
story from uh Lex Redman check it out he
says here's my conversation with Mark
Zuckerberg third time on his podcast but
this time we talked in the metaverse
Phil brought this up to me early on
these images right here you're seeing
this is CGI take a look at this Mark
Zuckerberg put on his metaverse headset
and and and headphones it then mapped
his face with the cameras all around it
creating a CGI realtime animation of him
as he's talking with Lex fridman that is
wild yo this is getting creepy and you
know I can only beg acceptance of the
Mark Zuckerberg
no no it's real easy to dunk on the
metaverse when it looks like we like a
Wii game but now it's like yo wait a
minute you know these these images you
seeing right now that we're playing on
the screen this is CGI right now Lex
looks real Mark looks a little plastic
but to be fair Mark always kind like I
knows which means it looks very real it
looks good right but uh Lex blinking and
sitting and sitting right there like
even his skin tone like the differences
in like you know the tone across his
face look at this uh pisos on Twitter
said no offense but your avatar appears
more human and lifelike than your real
formar apparently I crashed the NVC site
man dude Mr be is commenting on this
stuff
youo it's going to be crazy but here's
what you need to fear with something
like this and why we shouldn't build it
we shouldn't build it but it doesn't
matter it will be built if it's not
Zuckerberg someone will build it it's
because the more we create digital
spaces that can uh simulate reality the
closer you get to living in the pot and
eating the bugs because what's going to
happen is it's not going to be a
government mandate Joe Biden's not going
to go listen here Jack we'll put you in
the Pod you're going to eat the bugs and
they're go no and that'll never happen
what's going to happen is he's going to
say
listen for the people who can't afford
the the rent prices we have pod
personalized occupancy device and when
you go inside of it you strap on your
Mark Zuckerberg headset and instantly
you're in a 10,000 foot mansion where
you can walk around and all your friends
are there and it's no different than
reality now why and then what happens
once it won't just be that in fact it
might actually even be luxury at first
only the rich people can afford
then it
Wills for cheape Access you're going to
have commercials where it's like are you
YouTube ads I don't know we're not in
the AA commercials but it's going to be
like stop spending three grand a month
on rent don't be a dumbass get metaverse
then it's going to show like this dude
put on the goggles it's not really going
to be that corny or whatever but he's
going to be in a closet it's going to be
like Ready Player One meets em forers
the machine stops Ready Player One the
kid lived in a trailer right Traer
stacked on top of each other at least at
a trailer n in the in in in this your
home is going to be a bathroom your your
apartment will be a to will be a toilet
shower combo where you will go inside
you will strap into the metaverse and
lean back on like a a flat chair and
then or like like I don't know what You'
call it it's not a chair but something
to lean against you'll put the headset
on grab your controllers and then this
is the start and it only so like like
Phil was saying when it's we characters
it's silly and stupid everyone makes fun
of of it this this is getting scary
because now people are going to be like
you can actually have meetings and do
podcasts and interviews and we're
already there you know about 15 years
ago somebody showed me Second Life yeah
I remember explaining to me that and
they were super into it right yes and
people sold they made real money in the
real world selling products or concert
tickets or whatever in second life and
that was 15 years ago when it was really
cheesy and like even the computers were
cheesy at that time but I'm picturing we
saw well I call them the the pajama
Americans and we saw during Co the
amount of people since then and during
that just lost all respect for
themselves who just go out to the shops
now wearing their pajamas and Crocs oh I
hate that it's disgusting like fedman
yeah and they reinstituted the dress
code right and so I mean how far it just
too disgusting exactly and we're we're
subjected to this every time we go to
the grocery store now but how far are we
from the pajama Americans being totally
fine to just strap into the metaverse
and spend their fed bucks in the
metaverse getting their their Nike you
know Jordans and all I mean totally
renting renting fake clothing to wear it
to the party but this is why they want
to do it they want to do it because look
at nfts there is a big push for uh so uh
let me slow down gret tunberg says see
idea of infinite economic gross is
insane no their plan is digital products
that can be infinitely mass-produced
have fake value based on artificial
scarcity and then no one manufactures
anything and they're already there
because you can buy like Warcraft bro
exactly you buy and I mean in uh in
Destiny 2 you can buy different shaders
and for colors for your outfits you can
buy different armor yes but with with
with World of Warcraft going back to
2006 you could buy someone else's boots
y so not if it was soulbound though
right soulbound was when you get an item
and it couldn't be traded but you would
defeat a monster it would drop an
uncommon set of gloves the forest gloves
of agility or something and then you'd
go to someone and be like do you want it
and they'd be like yes and' be like I
want 10 bucks and then You' trade it to
them and then you'd get 10 bucks people
were trading gold in game so digital
digital items have already had a
Marketplace and they want to capitalize
off this it's crazy to me if you think
about mobile games there were farms in
China where people would just play World
of Warcraft and kill rabbits super gold
like all day long right and then the
funny thing happened when uh World of
Warcraft made it so you could buy gold
in game and it was for like you could
buy what was it how does it work you can
buy a token worth uh one month of
gameplay and then trade the token for
26,000 gold or something destroyed the
economy really why all of a sudden so in
World of Warcraft I love there needs to
be a research study on the E the
economics of MMOs but uh in the
beginning of the game you first start
you're super weak you walk outside and
there's like a a level five Bandit or
something and you fight him and then you
take his like linen cloth from his shirt
you sell it for a few pieces of copper
mhm the value early on is low once you
get to higher and higher levels the bad
guys drop more money right you defeat
the Bandit now he's got gold instead of
silver instead of copper as soon as you
could buy gold people start the game and
immediately just buy a ton of gold
they're like I'm not starting the game
with no money then what happens is the
lowest quality items that no one really
needs well look if all the new players
have access to massive amounts of
currency that used to be too hard to get
it used to be like you know 50 silver
for a stack of linen cloth now it's 10
gold why because new players have the
gold so supply and demand someone's got
it and they say I'll sell it and someone
says I'll give you a gold for no I'll
give you two I'll give you three I'll
give you four I'll give you five the
price is Skyrocket and you end up
watching inflation due to the mass
printing of money it's it's fascinating
how you could teach a 12-year-old
inflation by having them play World of
Warcraft that makes sense thanks Joe
Biden thanks Joe but anyway yeah the uh
the AI apocalypse is upon us I hope you
guys enjoyed it while it lasted you are
going to live in the Pod and it's not
that you're going to eat the bugs it's
that when you do eat the bugs it's going
to taste like cheesecake you know you're
going to you're going to put on your
metaverse headset you're going to attach
your wireless mag neuralink to the base
of your your your your your neck and
then when someone hands you a bowl of uh
boiled mashed cockroaches you're going
to be looking at a delicious brown sugar
oatmeal with cream on top and they'll
say that that's good because if you're
lactose intolerant you won't have any
problem and yes that's right and when
you're in the the temperature controlled
pod you won't have to worry about the
scary climate change going on outside
the front door you know this stuff is
all predicted in our fiction for you
know like over a century amem Foresters
the machine stops is really about this
everybody lives in a pod underground
because the world has become
uninhabitable and there's a machine that
pairs everybody up for mating and for
discussions there's a big View screen
and the Machine gives you everything
that you need and you never have to
leave your pod and this one woman ends
up having to leave her pod to go see her
son and she's like why do I even have to
come see you I see you on the telescreen
you know I made it with your father once
when the machine told me to or whatever
but it's very simp like we keep
predicting these things and we keep
doing exactly the thing that is going to
destroy us for the predictions I I just
I just thought of thought saw something
you know I'm going to I'm going to I'm
going to hit up Lex where can I get
these headsets cuz we spend a lot of
money on travel costs so we can do
inperson conversations with people
flying them out getting them hotels if
we can just ship them the headset it'll
be way cheaper than flying the whole
person so it's like here it be bad for
the brand yeah but no one will know the
difference they'll think they're sitting
in the room right I mean to be fair this
is all CGI AI generated anyway there's
no actual Tim pool Phil's not real
either the guests are made up on the
spot Libby is the only real person no
I'm totally
fake I was constructed in a lab that's
why I get everything wrong but we're
we're really close I don't think people
realize how close we are to full AI
podcasts where the the the host is going
to be fake none of the charact people
are going to be real yeah dude it's it's
it's mid journey is already crazy and we
played that uh capital of Conformity
video that video is so amazing the AI I
don't know I don't did you see it I
tweeted it out where it's like what the
future will look like and it's this this
AI generated video for the most it's AI
generated but a human put the together
and uh we're we're we're we're getting
really close to the point maybe within a
year where you're looking at this Mark
Zuckerberg stuff do you even if the
computer can map his mouth in real time
to what he's saying do they even need
actually actual Mark they don't no they
just they just call from what he's
previously said as soon as they have the
picture of his face you can program what
he's saying and it will just make it
look like he's talking mhm so you could
actually be like you wake up it's like
9:00 you're like oh I'm late man I got a
meeting in the morning you're like you
know uh computer uh put in my avatar and
have it go to work for me and then
everyone thinks they're talking to you
but it's just the AI simulating
you saying what it thinks you're going
to say and then you're sitting at home
playing video everyone it's just
everybody does that it's everybody's AI
right it's
just like probably you know play games
or whatever other degenerate things
people do on the internet what do we
think like just along these Lin like
what do what do we think about like
major events like sporting events where
during Co we were conditioned to watch
these events with no audience or the NBA
played in a like a hermetically sealed
dome for a while if I recall weird like
how would they just start having events
and then just AI the whole like crowd
and just it's like Black Mirror man
they'll just AI the players in Black
Mirror everybody's in that room tiny
rooms where every it's a TV screen all
around them and then it turns into the
like the the show set and they feel like
they're there but then the the set was
little me characters
clapping it's going to be like it's
going to be like this do you remember
the Twilight Zone where everybody dies
except for the guy who was in the
basement and he comes out and he he was
like in the vault so this Banker was uh
just he never wants to have to go to
work so at his on his lunch break he
just goes down to the Vault of the bank
he closes the door over a little bit and
he just sits there and reads where no
one will bother him and one day there's
like a nuclear blast and everyone dies
and he comes out of the Vault and he's
just like oh my goodness this is crazy
I'm just going to read forever his
glasses and then he he breaks his
glasses yeah he he's like you know it
was finally time but I feel like that
there'll be like just one person who
isn't fake and they'll finally just
realize like that they're the only
person left in the world and everything
is fake this would be a good story and
they have to make that decision do I go
into the AI metaverse and pretend I'm
fake too or do I ignore it I'd like to
um add on to my propaganda short film
idea where we paint the bad guys in a
more positive propag propagandistic
light and just also make a series where
we solve really stupid problems that
shows thought were profound like when
the guy breaks his glasses he goes he
doesn't say no it was time now he breaks
his glasses and goes oh I broke my
glasses puts them back on because he can
still see just not well goes to a
glasses store where they already have
thousands of pairs sitting there and
puts on a new pair of glasses I always
wondered that too instead he's just like
no no or like did all all glasses on
every else's face get vaporized right
well you don't see any dead bodies you
know that's always the thing is because
it's the Twilight Zone so they probably
had a small budget so you don't see a
lot of other people just maybe for
people who don't have glasses they don't
know this but like if your glasses break
you can still see it's just they're
broken plus I have like four pairs of
glasses I always have extra that'd be
funny if it's like no my glasses broke
good thing I got a second pair right
there we go where was I or just you have
them at home like you can get back home
no one's in those cars you can do a
modern I think drama did it where the
guy's eyeballs popped out and then and
he's like well it's a good thing I can
read Braille then his hands fall off I I
saw there's there was a uh I think it
was Family Guy that was making a joke it
was uh I think it was a brain Peter only
had one brain cell left and the Brain
Cell was like finally I can read and
then that was how I'm familiar with it
that's good that's good well are you
gonna Dan are you going to get the
neuralink I'm going to go with
no I'm going to choose to live in in
reality firmly rooted I think it's
inevitability yeah I I think it doesn't
matter what we say right now there it's
going to be a 100 years or whatever and
the kids are going to be fully plugged
in and they're going to be watching
archives in school and they're going to
be like here's an example of a 21st
century podcast and it's you being like
I'm not going to get the neuralink and
they were like Dan was 70 years old when
he died he had the neuralink by 56 you
know it's like right well the thing is I
mean if we have if the technology exists
it will be used that's just something
that is a truism throughout human
history you're not going to be able to
compete so uh it's like I was saying the
genetic engine in to well you're not
going to be able to compete in terms of
the workplace and and running your
business imagine if you're a restaurant
that doesn't have a phone well come on
like you got to have a phone right yeah
but there was most of human history
businesses did not have phones people
had to show up and talk to you then
phones came about if you're a pizza
place across stre from a pizza place and
you have no phone and they have phone
guess who's getting the deliveries right
not you now when people start
integrating metaverse connections it's
like the internet when the internet came
about if if you were online you an
advantage because it was easier to do
business with you Pizza Hut launched
their rudimentary little website for
ordering pizzas it was hilarious and
then eventually everybody's online I
remember oh go ahead I'm sorry I was
going to say businesses are going to
start using the metaverse in a similar
way and let's imagine that someone Works
in a metaverse environment so it's
easier for them to just while they're
already plugged in order pizza if you're
a business that doesn't offer it guess
what they're they're going to order from
the place that does right yeah that's
like if you're not on um like in New
York I always would order stuff from
seamless and it got to the point where
if it wasn't on seamless I wasn't going
to order it there you go cuz I already
had that all hooked up it was just like
well we we we we use we use a couple of
these apps and there's a bunch of
restaurants but if it's not on the app
we don't order right cuz like why would
you do that why would you actually go to
the trouble of calling someone and then
they're like hello what what did you say
what's your number dude just like kiosks
at fast food restaurants it's just so
much it's just so much easier yeah you
walk in you go
and what what bugs me is like I finally
do the self checkout at the stupid
grocer not the grocery store if I don't
have a lot of stuff I will do the self
checkout like at Walmart or whatever but
I still I hate it I dude it's always
broken I hate it the the Walmart out
here it's always broken and it's just
like you put everything they they have
the conveyor belt self checkout and then
you scan it it's like please put the
item in the baggage area and you're like
it's it's it's a can of it's it's it's a
12pack of of club soda what am I going
to put it in I can't put it in the
baggage area and like and then you you
have to wait for say I do not want to
bag this item and you're like and then
it goes please put the item in the
bagging area an item has been removed
and they like no the one that the one
that I love the one that I love is one
that just says help is on the way and
you're like but why what did I screw up
why are you helping me can't do anything
yeah why is this happening yeah that's
it's we look at like when when we're
supposed to like our lives are supposed
to get better with these convenient
technological advances and then they
just don't work like and they're going
to hook us all into machines like they
look that's NE link they're going to
turn and they're going to like just have
all police be robots and they're going
to be armed and you're just like H it's
going to be like in The Fifth Element
you know I think a combination of what
the Amazon store did and self checkout
is probably where we should go where
basically when you walk in like what
they're trying actually I'll just put it
this way the problem is the self
checkout is not the system of checking
out groceries is not built for an
automated system no they they can very
easily have a system where you load all
your grocery onto a conveyor belt if it
moves just across a sensor that checks
weight and the image of a camera and it
knows exactly what you've got if Amazon
can already know what you got based on
you picking the item up we don't need
you you don't need me you don't need me
going Boop like that's a waste of time
you just put on the conveyor belt it all
runs across you put in your gr you put
it in swipe your card you're done yeah y
this is a little off topic but uh Ted
Cruz was just just shared a
timcast.net on the show lion
lion ra lion not lion I said lion lion
good one another foreign born uh
presidential candidate that had dubious
you know some people question he
Canadian question his dad's a zodiac I
don't think I don't think he's didn't he
renounce Canadian citizenship or
something I don't know I don't think
he's actually Canadian I think that I
think he is what he was born in I think
one of his parents was Canadian but I I
think that because he was running for
president but he but he but he has he's
American but has has I think he's dual
citizen that could be okay that could be
yeah Canadians isn't that also kamla
Harris isn't she also part Canadian
wasn't she like in Quebec for a while no
I don't know about that she's Jamaican I
wish Jamaican Indian is what I remember
I'm pretty sure she spent time in
Montreal I might have that wrong she
definitely spent a a decent part of her
childhood growing up in Canada yeah I
thought that she was in
Quebec yeah when I remember like uh
speaking of technology that will be used
when I left school um I left uh college
for a year and then I went back and I
moved into an apartment that didn't have
a phone I never got a phone hooked up um
and there was a pay phone downstairs and
I could hear it ring from the window so
you know I'd tell people like uh ring
twice then hang up and call back and if
I'm home maybe I'll pick up the maybe
I'll run down and pick up the phone you
know not likely but when I went back to
school there was email and there hadn't
been email before and my friend the same
one who's now buying gold was like you
have to to like log into your email and
I was like no I'm not doing that and she
was like dude you have to log into your
email and I finally did and there were
assignments and like I had to go to
there were things that were changing the
time of the class and all this stuff and
like invitations to whatever and I was
like this is ludicrous why am I like
just give me a flyer you know but no all
right we're going to go to super chats a
good old days if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this YouTube channel share
the show with your friends become a
member by going to timcast.net join us
we're going to have a members only
uncensored show we're going to be
talking about this viral video actually
two of them where uh there was a trans
student who mercilessly attacked some uh
some other female students and it's
causing a big uproar but it's a little a
little spicy probably not for the kids
so we'll uh we'll keep this one F uh
we'll keep this show family friendly but
the uncensored show will be up at about
10 p.m. don't miss it and uh let's uh
read your super chats we got Mr battleon
he says what shoes do chickens wear
rebb
H and you paid me for that joke wow
thank you Clint Torres howdy people
howdy how do you Clint Clint you are
second Super chatter this time
around Bears fan and cheeseland says $2
closer to our alternative
economy yeah man guys download Public
Square and uh winning the culture War
can be as simple as using the Public
Square app to find businesses that share
your values and buying products from
them they have a map where you can see
all the businesses around you and it's
growing every day it's awesome in our
area we can see all the restaurants that
we'd rather go to I love it you told me
about that the other day and I started
looking at the near me and I was I was
very pleased pleasantly pleased by it
and you go into the business and you can
say hey I found you guys on Public
Square and they're going to be like yes
we love it it's so amazing high five and
then you know that like you're talking
to someone cool that's chill I like that
it's it's amazing when I when uh we
first found out about it that so many
businesses knew about it before we did
and I'm like we've got our we've got our
ears to the ground on all this stuff and
then so many businesses were already
using it when we first started uh
talking with the the team over Public
Square right I need to speak to them
eventually because my phone won't let me
use it it just say looking for square
and the app won't work for my device so
is it is your is your phone American uh
yes is it 20 years old maybe I don't
know it's a it is an S9 plus so it's old
I know right yeah that might be the
issue yeah but you know trying to avoid
get a new phone if I can all right
Raymond g Stanley Jr says guys I
remember a time when boys don't hit
girls today though if you're a boy but
pretend you're a girl you can most
certainly hit
girls well we got a lot to talk about
with that story but they'll be up in the
members only Stephen say says I had to
take out a loan from the credit union so
I could Super Chat and Tim won't read
them well I just read it right now you
took out a $10 loan I guess if your
credit card you know that's a loan Shane
Wilder says with Jen running for
president I would like to announce that
I too will be running on the Democratic
ticket no I'm not a Democrat but I am
running running on a platform of memes
and abolishing the fed well uh I don't
know what Jen's point was because he's
not a natural born US citizen so yeah I
guess that's not happening I don't know
I don't know why I think that is a rule
I like though that you have to be
natural born US citizen to run for
president I think that's a good one yeah
yeah I I'm not even an I agree yeah yeah
waffle sente says if Republicans were
smart they would be wargaming investing
and preparing for a campaign against
Nome everything is set up to fight Biden
and they may just drop Joe for Gavin
early to mid 2024 if I were the machine
that would be my plan yeah I Biden I
just what's what's GNA happen is is he G
to be given super soldier serum that de
AES him and then all of a sudden Hunter
Biden's gonna come out with with a stack
of evidence proving that it was actually
Trump who did all the things they
accused him of and then it's just like
it's going to be irrefutable evidence so
irrefutable that even Trump supporters
believe it did you watch any of the
impeachment inquiry today very little
bit same but uh I did go through the
evidence published by the house there's
too much I was trying I did a video and
I'm like scrolling through I'm like guys
I'm skipping the China stuff the Romania
stuff I'm only talking about the Ukraine
stuff and then after like 15 minutes I'm
like okay you get the point it's it's
insane how much evidence there is
there's a lot of evidence that he took
money from Ukraine to affect foreign
policy yeah no it really is crazy that
they have this graphic theyve built
where you scroll down and there's like
arrows and there's pictures and there's
news stories and there's links there's
Bank records and I'm just like this is
too much for me and then the media goes
there's no evidence and then Rasin says
there's no evidence and it's like if you
look at it and you're like that this is
what evidence looks like there's a bank
record showing the Biden family
receiving money from a Chinese business
like what what are they saying what
they're just lying these people are evil
it's crazy it's total
lies they obviously Nome is a is an
obvious candidate and it's like viable
but um have we totally shut the door on
Michelle Obama like is it that's the
scariest thing that I can come up with
cuz I think I think that she I think
that she would walk over any Republican
and not and not on any merits of her own
just the American people would be like
Obama love the name Michelle she's great
let's do this I don't think brains would
be left at the door and it would be all
voting for you know let's get Obama back
she's you know Obama but female so
that's Obama but a little better it
would be the most emotionally driven
mindless brain checkout vote ever and I
think she would Walt over anyone and it
is the scariest scenario in my op she
has no record I I don't think that it
matters no no no no no that's a positive
there's nothing to attack her on exactly
and anyone that does you like think of
all of the reasons you could call
someone all the bad names oh you're
attacking a woman you're attacking a
black woman you're not going to vote for
the that's why we have to win the
culture wars to get rid of all of that
trash uh we won't get a chance if she
runs maybe I mean that's why it's so
scary because there would she was just
paid
$750,000 to give a talk for like an hour
that indicates that that indicates a run
for president doomed so the here's how
it works if you want to run for
president nobody can give you if you're
running for president you can't get paid
more than like what is it 2700 or
something like that it's very small so
what happens is whenever someone is
preparing to run they these speeches
where they get paid so much money
Hillary Clinton did it with Goldman
Sachs now we're seeing Michelle Obama
get the 750k everyone's talking about it
why it's indicative of a presidential
run interesting you get paid a a massive
stick of cash for something arbitrary
like a consultation or a speech then
when you announce that's a donation
money there is nothing that just like
you said there is nothing you can attack
her with and any attacks that you that
you make against her it's all racist and
sexist transphobic oh my goodness okay
I'm not I'm not trying to bring up that
one wait real quick is is um is Michelle
Obama in predicted for their Democratic
party I don't think so yeah no wow she's
not even on the list she would Waltz
into the office like it is like it was
not like the doors were opened as soon
as she announces over cuz Donald Trump
could never not that I like none of this
is like something that I like but Donald
every attack that Donald Trump could
possibly muster she would be able to
deflect
instantaneously every single person in
the daytime TV stuff would be all they
would be right in her life already love
her it would be so over like the it
would be the obviously I think it would
be the worst thing that could happen to
the country because our policies would
be they would be they would be more
Progressive than than than Barack Obama
it would be the end of America and she
would walk in like it was nothing Y and
we be looking at like a lot of people
say Biden is Obama's third term in that
scenario we're looking at five
consecutive terms of Barack Obama that
is basically Perpetual Rule and it's
over all right the obscene unicorn says
every time crispy K cream called out
Trump last night I was expecting him to
run out of the stage to the G run on run
out onto the stage to the degeneration
theme song with a steel folding chair
like an episode of Monday Night Raw oh
okay I see I see I see yeah that's all
he had really ASA federali says I
recently forgot that Whitney Webb even
existed until I realized that Libby
emmens is a different extremely
intelligent journalist chick given that
they're not the same person have you
ever thought of having them both on
possibly with Alex Jones well sure I
guess yeah I don't know who that is but
I'm gonna go look it
up 2A Willie says the migrants being put
on the buses at the border under the
current political climate must be put on
the buses the border states being
inundated with mass migration cannot
sustain their own communities at this
rate right that was one of the arguments
the reason they're putting people on bus
and chipping them out is because they
have nothing to do with them they what
do they do yeah El Paso is destroyed
right isn't it like practically
decimated at this point yeah I mean even
I just spent time in Austin and I I I
used to go there to play South by
Southwest every year and uh it was a
great City at that time in my opinion um
and over the years I watched the
transformation of Austin even and uh the
last time I was just there a couple
months ago it felt inundated with
illegal aliens and I think it's
indisputable that it is but Austin's not
exactly on the border right and uh
that's what when people are talking
about Texas as a viable option for going
somewhere secure I say no I say
absolutely not that place is under siege
you have millions of people who we have
no idea who they are pouring into that
state we talk about the official numbers
and they're scary we we have no idea
what the the real numbers are why isn't
Greg Abbott just being like no we're not
doing this and securing the border with
the National Guard well even if he did
uh which we're seeing kind of a kind of
a limed effort toward a little bit a
little bit but we're watching Customs
and Border Protection agents and border
patrol open they're like opening doors
and dropping ladders and they're
counting they're going like 1 2 3 okay
we're good bring them all in yeah czy
they're cutting up the razor wire why
are they doing that cuz they're evil
like we watched this happen and you're
just like are you an idiot too why are
you doing that they're just following
orders they're evil the people are well
they are they must be possessed by some
kind of evil people people really got to
understand this like lahina really is
the good modern example did the cops
blocking the road in L know they were
murdering children no did they murder
children yes yes they did Mur children
they they that people were jumping out
of their car whole families they
murdered whole families yep and so when
Michael malice says there is no crime so
egregious a police officer would not
commit it up to and including the
execution of children every everyone
assumes what he's saying is that a cop
will be told go kill that child go yes
master like no no no he's he's not
saying that he's saying that when the
only Road out of
town uh is when when the PO when when
there's a major Wildfire destroying a
town and families are fleeing the police
will get orders to stop people from
driving out of town and then they'll all
burn to death while the cops watch
and and that is what happened that's
what they did a lot of people got out of
their cars and jumped in the water some
of those people went missing some of
those people drowned yep you're in a
cloud of smoke smoke inhalation kills
some of the people drowned some of the
people just were having trouble
breathing as it was some people were
still getting burned because you're in
the water but you're still near these
fires and I think people need to
understand uh movies and video games
really ruin this for people when they
see like lava and then like the people
will be jumping over The Lava or like
Star Wars
when Vader and and and Obi-Wan are
fighting over The Lava on Mustafar they
would instantly burst in Flames at
proximity yeah people don't get it man
uh so those cops did it and not only
that but then these officers or their
contemporaries and other agencies then
confiscated or blocked private Aid
coming in for the people who were still
in there like then they're just
compounding effect yep and there was a
local the police arrested one of the
residents a guy who lived there they
said you can't come back it's his house
he went into his house he probably had a
safe maybe had belongings he wanted to
get they said no they arrested him and
then the media reports it as looters and
trespassers as instead of homeowner
trying to get his stuff MH evil man
that's the scary reality of you know
what Michael Mouse is talking about do
we think like your average one ofthe mil
cop is evil not like not in the sense
where if like he's ordered to do
something evil he'll do it they'll be
ordered to do something they don't
understand and they'll carry it an
action which is tremendously evil
without realizing it well the state is
going to change the zoning there and end
up buying up all that land kicking
everybody out land grab it's a total
land grab they said it in the in like
just very shortly after the governor was
like oh we'll we'll help by buying up
this land yeah I know like what if that
were my land I'd be like the hell you're
buying up my land yes get off me you
know like I feel like that's me and the
government all the time just get off
just get off me Joseph says how much do
you give to make the world better as an
individual all of you the answer is no
one on the whole gives an f about anyone
they don't know this country is run by
main character syndrome Terror of death
while I certainly can respect the
perspective that most people are doing
that that certainly does not apply to I
would assume most people in this room
and it certainly does not apply to me
because if you want to know how much I
give to make the world better I probably
give like I don't know 10 or $20,000 to
a month to random people I don't know I
gave uh uh I I I I I don't go around
broadcasting it so I'll keep it
relatively vague but uh I just gave a
disabled veteran
$6,500 I gave an activist group fighting
against trans kids like 10 grand so yeah
I'm trying as hard as I can man not to
mention when when y'all pitched in and
we both together gave 50 Grand to Tim
Ballard for his new new effort that was
cool so and that's the super Chatters
right half of it was theirs and then to
be honest the other half came from
memberships to Tim cast.com so it's like
all you guys but yeah so how much do I
get as an individual bro I'm giving I'm
giving as much as I can I'm living
comfortably I'm doing well but you know
I got to be honest
man I I I don't understand how I look to
some of these people who are in
comparable positions to where timcast is
and I don't see them doing half of the
weird stuff that we've done I'm not
saying we're Saints or that we're the
best or anything I'm just saying like yo
we like so so the Time Square campaign
we bought 36 ads in Time Square for
several reasons but there's a reason why
Luke rowski and Michael M were on those
Billboards that's not to benefit timcast
it's because we I we need to win a
culture war and so asserting ourselves
in cultural space to the best of our
abilities I wish we made a $100 million
a year I just own Time Square and force
ABC News Nasdaq all these people to look
at our ads every single day so that we
can take over we do what we can right I
do I like I'm I exert as much as I can
to do this stuff I wish and I say it all
the time there's so many wealthy
powerful people that could snap their
fingers and and set the cultural
conversation and they don't do it yeah
but yeah man I do I do appreciate the
Super Chat because I know you know what
you're saying is a generality about most
people and you're correct most people
don't care I will say
though when I when I talk to a lot of
the guests that come on this show always
talk about how amazing the timcast
audience is and it's something it's it's
unlike anything they've ever seen and I
think what it
is the average person I'll meet someone
and they're a fan of one show or the
other and they'll shake my hand I meet
someone who watches timcast and they've
got all these ideas and they they're
elaborating on things we've talked about
and they want to tell you all these
ideas like it's really fascinating to me
and I'm like yeah I think the people who
watch timcast are like paying attention
a lot and and deeply care and want want
to win and make changes so I really do
appreciate all of you guys and Joseph I
do appreciate the comment because I
think it is a big problem that most
people don't care that's why you see
these videos where they go to Times
Square and they ask people questions
they don't know anything no because if
it doesn't affect them they don't care
about it mhm and I will also add we are
afflicted
by the inability to see beyond what the
the cultural standards are and what I
mean is if it's not reported news and
it's not prominent and and being shared
then we don't know what happened then we
don't talk about it and so you'll get
people being like why aren't you talking
about this problem and it's like I don't
know enough about it right so we we only
talk about what we can what we what we
know and what we we try to the problems
we try to solve let's grab some more
Super chats will Johnson says what's
going on with Katie Hobs easy she's
traveling out of state and Arizona
requires the governor be in state that
means if she travels out of state there
has to be an acting Governor takeover
because there's no lieutenant governor
then they're having the I think the
secret the treasurer yeah that's right
treasur for a day yeah so it's just like
it's it's nothing nothing's happen it's
really not a big deal yeah there was a
great example of of actually something
happening in Idaho during coid when the
the governor there would go out of town
the lieutenant governor I believe her
name was meechum every time he would
leave town she would basically um freeze
all of the coid orders that he had
issued so masking and all that stuff and
then uh he would come back into town and
put it back to the way it was but that
was an example of actually someone
taking action very revolutionary action
in the second highest you know power in
the state every time the governor would
leave so interesting things can happen
when the governor goes away but this one
looks like a nothing Burger apparently
well in New York Laticia James and uh
Kathy hokel
pushed Cuomo out of office on trumped up
uh sexual misconduct charges and then
all the charges got dropped because
there was absolutely no evidence of
anything at all it was a coup and now
there's Kathy hok and she is awful and
she's uh very destructive in the state a
good example of uh you know what they
replace this terrible thing with often
is even worse it's even worse what you
wish for yeah it was like you know a
better version of Biden uh and AA har
and KLA Harris is now in charge
basically but yeah Kathy hok is a
disaster yeah and it was totally a coup
all right Doss wood says all Chen does
is lie so no no surprise there I love
malice but when Chen was on his show
spewing Progressive BS even saying the
horse thing was out of context I watched
it it wasn't malice gave zero push back
I was
shocked I don't I what what could the
context be on the horse thing could it
be that Jen says right before this video
hey hey guys I'm going to say something
really really crazy it's going to be
hilarious all right here we go if I was
a benevolent is that because that's out
of context or what if he said something
like you know I watched this funny
comedy where there was this uh this this
guy who took over the country and he
says if I was a like those things matter
because that that does happen I've seen
so so much out of context Clips where
someone will be like did you hear what
what Trump was saying I am the greatest
blah blah blah blah blah and then
they'll quote and be like this person
said this it's a l it's literal truth
meaning you said it you were quoting
someone else but you said it therefore
they can report it so you know whatever
man if if if he wants to walk away from
that I absolutely will let Jen yuger
walk away if he says no no no that's not
what I believe I don't like that I'll
bet okay dude you okay we'll we'll we'll
just sweep that one away and you just
never go there again yeah never say that
again yeah that's weird one we'll let
you we'll let you continue just just you
know has he and I guess he hasn't said
anything like that since right no no no
and and a lot of people criticize him
for his statements on the Armenian
Genocide which he did apologize for and
just like dude come on man he needs to
change the name of the program I just
right all right there's no reason not to
do it and they keep defending yo The
Young Turks committed the Armenian
Genocide yeah just just change the name
man and I don't mean Jen yuger The Young
Turks they use the name because I guess
he's Turkish and The Young Turks is is
also synonymous with like young upstarts
but no it doesn't make better it's like
saying you're a young German company so
therefore we're going to call with the
Hitler Youth it makes zero sense it's
weird I went to politicon and there were
Armenian protesters yeah oh interesting
yeah with signs and they were like we
like The Young Turks Jen is good he's
great we please please please change
your name and he won't do it and we
we're like we're upset he's doing it
we're trying not to be mad about it and
I was like this the guy said he's like
imagine they called themselves Hitler
Youth like come on and I'm like I agree
with you I don't know just just change
the name yeah it's as simple as that
what you do is you stop calling it Young
Turks you start calling it tyt and then
eventually you you call it uh you change
the the Turks to Something Different
yeah and so it's like the young young
Turtles there you go hey Turtles
everybody likes turtles every lik
turtles yeah Turtles are great they sit
there and they put their legs out to dry
off
T-Rexes lady an Ellum did it lady a now
right yeah but but it was funny cuz
there's like this this female black
singer who was called lady a and so they
stole her name and infringed on her
market and she's like hey wait what are
you doing so like in their effort to not
be racist they got accus of even more
racism yeah just bro who cares if your
group is called lady antab Bellum
they're like well it's a re it's a
reference to Civil War so what no one
cares what does Anabell mean Before the
War uh yeah yeah before Anum yeah and
then what uh what's after how do you say
after it was it was the Reconstruction
was after well there's a word for post
Bellum I don't now post Bellum post
Bellum yeah not sure I have to look it
up yeah what do we got we got a super
jit steo says last time I bothered you
guys I ordered a box of TP before Co
lockdown hit this time I'm warning you
all bullets beans and bandages training
is a must and physical fitness increases
your chance of survival complacency is a
killer agreed yes you know uh if it all
breaks down bullets are going to be
currency and it's not because of this
idea that we're fighting each other
hunting okay you want to get food you
want to be able to hunt your ammunition
is is a key way to do it but night
vision bro night vision that deer is
going to be staring you in the face
you're going to be 3 feet in front of it
reaching out with your big muscular
survivalist hands after several years in
the wilderness and you're going to grab
his handlers and just snap it and he's
never going to see it coming your wife's
going to be standing behind you with
night vision goggles and she's going to
be like that was awesome night vision is
great if you if you're going to take up
a position though thermal is good too
but thermal doesn't work for movement
we've got we've probably got like 20
deer that live on the property the
people in in in Northern Virginia around
this area they need to take up hunting
because there are too A boat like there
are so many deer it is dangerous yeah
yeah they I'm always scared driving at
night around here they were so they they
were starving last year because they
were too many yeah oh man the funny
thing is the tree line is all perfectly
cut mhm and and we we're like when we
first came here we're like how is the
how are the how's the tree line
perfectly cut and it's like cuz the deer
the deer they keep it trim you know yeah
where are we at grab some super
chats what is it North says it's SM to
invest in lead rather than gold Fair yes
I don't know how effective a golden
bullet would be like pure gold it would
just flatten and probably shatter yeah
it would probably flatten I mean I guess
that has it has its purpose you know
like like like a a lethal but like
somewhat less
lethal softer actually that might be
more lethal yeah I don't know all right
we'll grab some more Super chats sa
federali says bullets aren't valuable as
currency because they can be measured
for they can't be measured for Quality
one day you'll have a box of 9 mimet
mostly full of sand you're going to fire
round you get to test them um the same
thing can can be said for gold you have
no idea if they're giving you real gold
or fake gold going to bite it and be
like oh look it worked so yeah yeah I
mean yeah what you do is someone comes
to you and says I want to buy uh you
know that that that succulent pig roast
that you have for my family and you say
that's going to be one box a 9
millimeter and they say I got you right
here and they're going to slam in the
table then you're going to open it up
and you're going to pull out one at
random and you're going to load it and
you're going to test it and you're going
to say okay maybe the guy gave you half
Duds or he one tenth Duds and hoping you
don't notice but at the very least a
random test can confirm you're likely
getting a good box of ammunition did you
see the thing in Dublin where it was
like like illegal immigrants were
roasting a dog whoa I saw the rats in
New York well people roasting rats yeah
yep literally I don't know if that was a
real video cuz it could just be a fake
video someone made that would be wormy
and really bad for you yeah but the
worms get cooked yeah but it's still and
it's not it's not like Pleasant like as
an idea yeah I mean anyway super nasty
but that yeah they're cooking they're
roasting dogs on a spit in
Dublin my thing about the bugs when like
I don't want to eat the bugs I'm like
y'all need to start getting ready to eat
the bugs not because we're going to lose
the culture War but because if an
economic crisis hits you need to get
comfortable with eating some things you
do not want to eat my my grand so I was
I was at my grandpa's house this is 20
some years ago rest in peace and uh I
made a sandwich before we were leaving
and when I I made a peanut butter and
jelly and then I looked there was mold
on the edge and I was like ah and he's
like what's wrong and I was like the
bread's mold he goes so what and I was
like well I'm not going to eat it and he
walks over and he grabs it he goes takes
a big bite he goes you don't know what
we ate in the depression or something
like that y I was like
ah my grandfather my grandfather in the
depression one of my grandfathers he
forged for mushrooms oh yeah and sold
them and he was a he was like pretty
young at the time and after that period
of life was over he never ate a mushroom
again in his life like that was it that
was it for him and mushroom I'm not fan
of mushrooms I don't blame him all right
not Bob Saget says I ran a bot Farm back
in 2006 in World of Warcraft I would
have it running during the day while I
was at school I made thousands of
dollars selling gold to other kids the
MMO gold market is a billion dollar
industry wow wow that's crazy crazy man
and then once we're in the metaverse and
like that's all our lives yeah yeah I
don't like it yeah no it's not good but
you know what you're probably already in
it I'll be that last person like in F
you're probably already in it right now
I'm in the metaverse right now it's a
simulation
yeah but saying it's a simulation and
saying we were created by God are almost
the same thing right exactly and so you
know what you were in is basically God
created this universe you plugged your
brain in and woke up here well maybe but
I'm still not doing it if the Sim s
simulation theorists should probably
already believe they're
in in by choice a matrix my son said
that like when we first moved out this
way he was like Mom we are at the edge
of the simulation
you should have went like this you
should have
went you are
correct I don't think the camera could
capture what I just did what are we
going to do what are we going to do out
here cuz we kept going in places and
like there would be either no staff at
all or the staff would just look at us
and then keep doing what they were doing
and like never take our order they'd be
like we don't like you New Yorker Taps
around these we wouldn't even say
anything like we went into some ice
cream place and they just looked at us
and kept helping the drivethru and I was
like do we have to get in the drivethru
to get ice cream well the the the CPU
power this far out of the simulation is
really low yeah so the NPCs
are yeah well so we did get in the
Drive-Thru and then we got ice cream
that way and then we got out of the car
and ate the ice cream like it was it was
really weird all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and right now head over to
timcast.net
if you want to see more cultural
victories as a member you help us with
building the coffee shop setting up
these Live Events making music we're
working on setting up short films we
have a video game in the works we're
going to have to release the code
because this one kind of you know didn't
go as far as we wanted to working on a
card game which will hopefully come out
and uh building a new studio and we have
a bunch of projects in the works we want
to create an anti- an anti-time Square
in Martinsburg West Virginia Revitalize
the area and overall just uh win a
culture War so join timcast.net
and uh you'll get access to the
uncensored show which is coming up in a
few minutes you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
everywhere at timcast Dan do you want to
shout anything out sure yeah you can
find me uh on Twitter real Dan Lyman and
also border Hawk at border hawk. newws
and Border Hawk news on
Twitter I am Phil leonti Phil that
remains on X or Twix if you want to call
it that Phil that remains official on
Instagram the band is All That Remains
we available on Apple music Spotify uh
uh Pandora Amazon music YouTube you know
the
internet I'm Libby Emmons you can find
me at Libby emmens on Twitter um and at
theost
millennial.age so head on over pleasure
to meet you Dan uh this is a fun episode
uh I am surge.com on Twix and I'm going
to keep calling it Twix cuz it's a good
one yeah left and right Twix you know
yeah anyways uh let's get to that after
show all right everybody we will see you
all over at timcast.net